GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS HEARING IF YOU'RE
KILEY AND TELLS ME SO I CAN
MAKE A FEW ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THOSE THAT MADE
IT POSSIBLE TO ALLOW US TO HEAR
BILLS IN THE CAPITAL TODAY.
THIS INCLUDES STAFF FROM
ASSEMBLY ROLES ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS AND LEGISLATIVE DATA
CENTER WHO PUT IN MANY HOURS TO
HELP PROCURE AND CONFIGURE NEW
EQUIPMENT TECHNOLOGY FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO. FOCUS ON THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION FAR HEARINGS DUE
TO THE CONTINUED STATE HOME
ORDERS WERE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AT THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL
SO WE ONLY BE ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN PERSON
IN THE HEARINGS. WERE ALSO
REQUIRING MASS B. AND THIS IS
IN MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WHETHER
YOU WORK HERE IN THE ROOM. OR
AT VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. WE
ALSO HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES TODAY FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM TODAY IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF. AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC MEDIA
AND MEDIA SO THAT WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF SPACING
THEY'RE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE IN
THE CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE HERE
IN THE ROOM IF MANY ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM
ELECTED TESTIFYING TO BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND. THE
LAST THAT YOU APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE
TO TESTIFY INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WILL HAVE SOME BILLS.
WITNESSES AND MAKING USE OF ONE
OF OUR WITNESSES. VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS WERE LOCATED
HERE IN THE CAPITAL. IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS THOSE
WITNESSES. WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO THAT MEMBERS CAN
WATCH THE TESTIMONY LIVE. FOR
DIAL IN WITNESSES WILL BE USING
A MODERATE A TELEPHONE SERVICE.
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 ACCESS CODE TWO
FOUR. TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN
AGAIN THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. 877-692-8957
ACCESS CODE. TWO FOUR TWO SIX
TWO THREE SEVEN. CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AS WELL AS YOUR TV
SCREEN THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE
WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE
BASED ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE A BILL IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A
MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL. YOU WILL REMAIN ON A LIVE
LINE NEED TO MEET YOURSELF
UNTIL YOUR CALL TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THIS MODERATE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE. AT ERROR
CODE. 916-319-3301 AGAIN THAT'S
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
THREE THREE ZERO ONE. WE'D LIKE
TO ALSO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WITNESS TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. NOW FOR ME MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. IN ORDER TO
RESPOND TO ROLL CALL OR ASK A
QUESTION OR PROVIDE A COMMENT
PLEASE FRAZIER MICROPHONE.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR MICROPHONE IF
YOU'RE SPEAKING IN RECOGNITION
TO ASK A QUESTION OR TO MAKE A
COMMENT AS IT WILL BETTER HELP
A STAFF. CONTROL THE SOUND
CONSUL. ALSO AT THE END OF THE
HEARING WILL ONLY RUN THROUGH
THE BILLS ONE TIME FOR AT ON
WILL NORMALLY RUN THROUGH
SEVERAL TIMES. THROUGH A
DIFFERENT PROCESS. FINALLY LET
ME ALSO JUST MENTION THAT WE
HAVE FIVE BILLS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH SHOULD BE TAKEN
UP. ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM
STATUS WOULD IT IS APPEARS THAT
WE DO THAT IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SB FIVE SEVEN THREE BY
SENATOR CHIANG. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB SIX FIVE THREE
BY SENATOR CHIANG. FILE ITEM
THREE. SB ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT S. B. TWELVE FORTY
FOUR BY SENATOR BRADFORD. AND
ALSO FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR WHICH IS
US SENATE COMMITTEE BILL AGAIN
THERE ARE FIVE BILLS ON CONSENT.
REMINDER THAT SHE WITNESSES
WILL GET A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES PER SIDE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES PLEASE ONLY STATE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
LASTLY LET ME. TAKE A MOMENT TO
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA WILL
BE JOINING OUR COMMITTEE TODAY
AS SELVES. I HOPE THAT YOU'LL
STAY PERMANENT TOO SO WE CAN BE
FOR. FULL AND READY TO GO. OKAY
THAT IT GETS US TO SOME OF THAT
HOW'S KIDDING ITEMS ONE NOW
THEN IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO IT CAN BE FIXED THERE
WOULD YOU PLEASE STOP SUPPORT.
LARA HERE WELL HERE ARAMBULA.
RIVER HERE HELLO. I'M HERE
CHINA AND HERE JOKES TO HEAR
DOLLY DEAL HERE EGGMAN. EGGMAN
HERE FLOOR FLOOR HERE FONG FROM
HERE GIPSON. GIVEN HERE GLORIA
GLORIA PRESENT GRAYSON HARPER
HOLDEN. HOLDEN HERE IRWIN.
MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA HERE
MULLIN OBERNOLTE ANOTHER HERE
FIFTEEN. WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WOULD LIKE
TO NOW ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR
CONSENT IT'S A- IS A MOTION AND
SECOND ON ITEMS A CONSENT.
PRETTY SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I DON'T CONFRONT WITH THE
MOTION TO PASTOR APPROACH TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS SB FIVE
SEVEN THREE SB SIX FIVE THREE
SB ONE ONE EIGHT NINE SB
SEVENTEEN FOR A FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR MOTION WITH THE
JUSTA DO PASS THIS SB TWELVE
FORTY FOUR. LOW HI LOW HI
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM.
WHEN I CHEN. CHENNAI TRUE JULY
CUNNINGHAM THE DAILY THE WAY I.
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE. FOUR FOR ON
FARM. FONG I GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GLORIA WHERE I GRAYSON GRAYSON
AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
THIRTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN
OBERNOLTE REALTY I THINK.
CONNECT HUNDRED FIFTEEN VOTES
THE BUILD UP WITH THE WORLD IN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS IF YOU. DID
YOU GET A LITTLE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THAT PASSED CONSENT
AND AGAINST A COLLEGE FOR A
POINT OF INFORMATION- WE HAVE
DONE OUR BEST TO HEAR ALL
COMMITTEE BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
BEFORE US INCLUDING CONSENTING
A NUMBER OF BILLS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLES AS BEST AS
POSSIBLE SO WE WANT TO GIVE
DIFFERENCE TO OUR FELLOW
COLLEAGUES ON THE SENATE.
HAVING SAID THAT WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS AB THIRTY THREE THIRTY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON. I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY WHICH AUTHORIZES.
FEE INCREASES FOR VARIOUS
BOARDS UNDER THE PART OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS IN THE STATE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM KNOWN AS CURES. I WANT
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING IS AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS THE COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATION TO REDUCE SECURE
SPEAK. FOR FOURTEEN DOLLARS TO
TWELVE DOLLARS. AND CHANGE THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OF THE CURES B.
FROM JANUARY. TO APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO ALIGN WITH THE
CURRENT FEE SCHEDULE. AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY AUTHORIZES. BE
INCREASES FOR THE BOARD OF
ACUPUNCTURE BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES. AND PODIA ETTRICK
MEDICINE TO ADDRESSED BUDGET
SHORTFALLS. WITHOUT A STATUTORY
FEE CHANGED. THE PROGRAMS OF
RISK FINANCIAL INSOLVENCY.
COMPROMISING PUBLIC SAFETY AND
CREATING SIGNIFICANT LICENSING
BACKLOGS. ADDITIONALLY THE
CURES V. INCREASES WILL BE USED
TO REIMBURSE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOR THE MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATION. OF THE CURES SYSTEM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WITH ME ON THE PHONE LINE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS THE
CIA DIRECTOR KIM KIRCH MEYER
AND AMY JARVIS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CHRIS
RYAN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. IS ALSO AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON DOJ
CURES COSTS THANK YOU RESPECT
LAST NIGHT OF. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY CALDERON AND JUST
BEFORE WE GET INTO SOME OF THE
WITNESSES WE HAVE THIS BY FOR
US. AS A REQUEST BASICALLY FROM
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS. IT
WAS OUR DESIRE TO HAVE THIS
SCENE SIMILARLY IN. A BUDGET
COMMITTEE AS IT HAS BEEN AN
SENATE COMMITTEE BUT YOU ARE
DOING THEIR DUE DILIGENCE IN
HELPING SHEPHERD THIS THROUGH
AND I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS DOES ALSO DOES ALSO
ENJOYED DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE'VE ASKED. OF RESPECTIVE
REPRESENTED FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND YOU SAY TO HELP
ARTICULATE. THE SPECIFIC NEED
pBUT AGAIN I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MAJORITY LEADER CALDERON FOR
HELPING TO THAT OF FOR THE
BODY. SO HAVING SAID THAT UP.
IF THE OPERATOR WERE KIND THEY
OPEN UP TO ALLOW FOR THE KEY
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY AND OFFER
ANY. COMMENTS. OPERATOR ARE YOU
DRIVING. YES THIS IS AMY
GARDNER FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. OKAY LET YOU CAN HEAR
ME YES CAN YOU AND I APPRECIATE
YOU THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES AND THURMOND AND WE
SUPPORT AN AGREEMENT THE
CHANGE- TO TWELVE DOLLARS AS
NOTED. AND EFFECTIVE APRIL
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
RECOGNIZING THAT THE OTHER FEES
AND THE BILL AND ARE ALL
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE DID WANT TO NOTE-
AS WE HAVE STATED PREVIOUSLY
THAT THERE MIGHT BE SOME
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES AND IN
OUR ABILITY TO. IMPLEMENT THOSE
ALL AFFECTED JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BECAUSE THERE
IS A TIME LAG IN TERMS OF THE
HEIGHTS HE CHANGES THAT NEED TO
BE MADE BY THE ACA FOR
IMPLEMENTATION- AS WELL AS
NOTIFYING ALL THE LICENSEES AT
THE KEY CHANGES. AND THE AND
THE TCA ANDY OKAY AS YOU HAVE
NOTED ARE BOTH AVAILABLE IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS AND WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THIS TURKEY
INCREASED RECOGNIZING THAT IT
IS NECESSARY AND WE WILL HAVE
CONTINUED DISCUSSIONS- THAT.
LEVEL ENTRY HAS CHANGED OVER
TIME AB LIKE EVERYTHING THINGS
CHANGED HI WE APPRECIATE THAT
THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN SO OPEN
TO- WORKING WITH A TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE RIGHT LEVEL OF HE
IS AT THAT. POINT. IN TIME SO
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. KIMBERLY
CLARK FIRE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS- I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON FOR THE RING AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY WHICH INCLUDES FEE
INCREASES FOR THE THREE BOARD
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT THE
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE BOARD
THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES AFFORDABILITY AND
CHECK MEDICAL PUT AFTER MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. ON THESE
BOARDS AS STATED WILL BECOME
INSOLVENT WITHOUT THE FEE
INCREASES IN THE FEES BEING
PROPOSED ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THE ARTISTS THAT HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED AND MADE AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC AGAIN WE'RE HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND ON THE
PUBLIC GOING TODAY WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM EACH OF
THE THREE BOARD. WILL ALSO BE
MOVING FORWARD I'M IN THIS BILL
THAT THE INCREASE WITH FOR THE-
I'M CARE SYSTEM- AND THIS IS A
FEAT THAT IS- PAID BY THE
LICENSEES OF THE DEPARTMENT WHO
CAN PRESCRIBE ORDER ADMINISTER
FURNISHED OR THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES AND AGAIN WITHOUT
THESE ADDITIONAL FEES. WE WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO ADMINISTER THE
SYSTEM I MEAN IT WILL BECOME
INVOLVED BUT AND WE ALSO AGREE
WITH THOSE CHANGES THAT WERE
WERE MADE PREVIOUSLY AND. HERE
WE ARE HERE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK THE OP FOR KEY WHEN
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ARE THERE
NOW ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO ADD THEIR
SUPPORT SIMPLY NAY MANIPULATION
IF YOU WISH TO DO SO OPERATOR
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT NAME AN AFFILIATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO.
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IN ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
FIRST OF ALL TO LINE NUMBER ONE
FOURTEEN LINE IS OPEN. WISEMAN
HOMES REPRESENTING THE BOARD
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES OF ORCHARD
PARK THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
THAT INCREASES BY. THANK. NEXT
OPEN ONLINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU KINDLY GOOD MORNING
HONORABLE CARILLO AND ON THE
MEMBERSHIP COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
BENJAMIN YES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ACT BEFORE I'M HERE
TO MAKE IT WORK- REPORTER FOR
INCREASING THE AMOUNT WITH.
BACKING A FIVE THANK. I'M GOOD
ACTORS. THANK YOU VERY. WHAT
CAN I DO LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FOURTEEN
LINE FOURTEEN LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HI EVERYBODY THIS IS ONE IS ONE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER. A PODIATRIC
MEDICAL BORDER CALIFORNIA OR
YOU. ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE HAVE NO RESPONSE
NINE ONE SIXTEEN I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU FOR PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM OPERATOR WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE NOW OPEN UP
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION M. OPERATOR ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN CHAU OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. BUT THE INITIAL
OPPOSITION TO BE PRESSED ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. I HAVE NO ONE
SHOWING OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MA'AM OPERATOR NUMBER
IN THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WISHING TO SPEAK TO PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON THE ITEM
BEFORE US BEGIN WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION I JUST WANTED TO
ASK- ESPECIALLY. I THINK
DEPARTMENT FINANCE WOULD BE IF
THEY'RE STILL ON THE LINE. TO
BE ABLE TO ASK A QUESTION AND
THAT IS- I DID READ THE
MATERIAL BUT JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION THE ACTUAL NEED.
TO INCREASE THE FEE AND I
BELIEVE. THERE THE EXISTING VIA
SIX DOLLARS. THE INITIAL ASK
WAS TO INCREASE IT TO FOURTEEN
IT'S NOW BEEN BACK DOWN TO
TWELVE. SO WHAT IS THE ACTUAL
NEED TO INCREASE THE FREE AND-
IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY.
UNDER EXISTING CONDITIONS IT'S
A REASONABLE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH OPERATING AND MAINTAINING.
CURES SO IS IT BECAUSE SIX
DOLLARS WAS JUST NOT ENOUGH. OR
IS IT BECAUSE THERE ARE LESS
LICENSEES PAYING THE FEE. GREAT
I ALSO- BEFORE WE GET TO THAT
QUESTION ANSWERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I ALSO
WANT TO. MAKE IT A TO MAKE NOTE
THAT THE BOARD REPRESENTATIVES
FOR THE BORDER- THE ACUPUNCTURE
BOARD. OF PODIATRY IN
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES ARE ALSO ON
THE LINE AS WELL TOO SO AGAIN
IF WE COULD GET CLARIFICATION
FROM THE REPRESENTED FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ANY
TRAVIS AGAIN AND YET OF A FIXED
DOLLAR ANNUAL FEE IS AFFECT THE
LICENSEES AUTHORIZED TO
PRESCRIBE ORDER ADMINISTER
FURNISHED OR DEFENSE SCHEDULED
TO THREE OR FOUR CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES. THE NUMBER
LICENSEES HAVEN'T CHANGED THAT
I'M AWARE OF BUT I WILL AND
ELECT HIM CHRIS MEYER AND LET
US KNOW IF THAT IS NOT
ACCURATE. AND WHAT HAS CHANGED
THOUGH AND WHY WE BONTA THE
TWELVE DOLLARS IS WHEN WE
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED IT AT
FOURTEEN AND- THAT THE STATE
HAD NOT CLOSED THERE ARE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN YEAR AND
FISCAL PROCESS. AND SO THERE
WERE SOME SAVINGS REALIZED
THERE AND THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
RE EVALUATE THE FEE AMOUNT AND
UPDATED A PHONE THAT NEW
INFORMATION. I KEEP A CLEAN
WHEN A SOME OF THE COSTS
DRIVERS ARE. BILLS AND OF
LEGISLATION THAT THEN REQUIRE
IMPLEMENTATION BY DOJ AND WHILE
THE BILLS THEMSELVES DON'T HAVE
AN APPROPRIATION WE DO GO
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS
EVERY YEAR. AND IDENTIFY AREAS
WHERE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
MIGHT NEED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO IMPLEMENT THOSE BELLS. AND
SO. IN THAT PROCESS AND IT HI
YOU MAY RECALL WHEN WE WERE
NEGOTIATING THE FINAL BUDGET
ONE OF THE BILL THAT WAS
INCLUDED WHEN EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT. IT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE F. AND THAT WE ALSO
KNEW WOULD REQUIRE. CONTRIBUTED
NEED FOR A FEE INCREASE THAT
WOULD SUBSEQUENTLY MOVED FROM
THE BUDGET WHILE WE WORK ON THE
ISSUE AND IT IS NOW BACK IN.
THE PROPOSED BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
OR CONSIDERATION AND APPROVAL.
AND HE OKAY WOULD BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE STICK WITH THAT TO THE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH ANY
ADULTS HAVE RECENTLY. IF YOU
WANT GO BACK TO WHATEVER BILL
AND I GIVE THE TO EACH OF THE
INDIVIDUAL. BUILT ON THE BUT
THEY WERE FOR BILLS THAT WERE
CAP. AND RESULTED IN BY OF HER.
FOR THE NINETY TWENTY ACROSS.
AND AT THE TIME OF THE APPROVAL
OF THE LARGEST. AND THE ADMIN.
WHERE WHERE WOULD. CONTRIBUTE
TO THE FOR THE INCREASE. AND AS
I AND A- IT AND DEFEAT. IT WILL
BE IN EFFECT OUR- APRIL FIRST
TWENTY ONE CURRENT IS SIX
DOLLARS. IT WILL BE AND TWELVE
DOLLARS EFFECTIVE APRIL FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IT'LL BE
SETBACK RATE UNTIL MARCH THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE AT
WHICH TIME IT WILL BE REDUCED
DOWN TO NINE DOLLARS. AND
BEGINNING AT JULY FIRST TWENTY
THREE TWO FOUR EIGHT FOUR APRIL
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AS
WE THINK THAT IS WHAT IS
NECESSARY BASED ON WHAT WE KNOW
RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF THE COST.
BEING INCURRED AND BY BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE AND DCS. AND
WITH THAT A. AS- HOPE THAT THE
DAY OR DCA. CAN AT ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. WITH
ANY OTHER MEMBER OF WOULD WISH
TO ADD AN ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATION AT THIS TIME-
FROM REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
RESPECTIVE BOARDS OR DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE. OKAY HEARING NONE-
MEMBERS- FOR GIVE ME A LOT WAS
TO CHECK THE REMOTE VIEWING
ROOM I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
ONE INDIVIDUALS IN THE REMOTE
VIEWING ROOM. A WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SO IF THE
START OF A KILEY ALLOW THE-
INDIVIDUAL TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION IN THE REMOTE
VIEWING ROOM. I THINK YOU GUYS
ALL SEE AND HEAR ME. WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU KELLY BEAM HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
PROVIDERS ARE STRONG SUPPORTERS
OF THE CURES DATABASE
RECOGNIZING ITS POTENTIAL TO
PROVIDE VALUABLE CLINICAL
INFORMATION THAT SUPPORTS
APPROPRIATE PRESCRIBING OF
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. WELL
THERE MIGHT BE A COST TO MAKE
NECESSARY TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
THE DATABASE THE PROPOSED
INCREASE REQUESTED SEEMS
EXCESSIVE SENTIMENTALITY OJ
PROJECTS THE TECHNICAL CHANGES
TO COST MORE THAN THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM OVERALL THAT WAS
COMPLETED IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE AN AUTHOR'S WORK ON
THIS COMPONENTOF THE BILL IT
WAS A QUICK TURNAROUND. THE DUE
DILIGENCE OF THE PROPOSED
INCREASE HELP TO SHED LIGHT ON
THE CURRENT CONDITION OF THE
FUND. HOW MUCH OF THE CURRENT
FEET AT COULD COVER THE SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS. AND JUST HOW MUCH
OF AN INCREASE IS JUSTIFIED
ACROSS ALL THE HEALTHCARE
LICENSEES THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
THE CURES DATABASE. I WILL TAKE
THESE MOMENTS BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS FOR AN UPDATED POSITION
BUT WE THINK YOU. THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS ARE MEMBERS
REQUEST THE LEGISLATURE TO LOOK
INTO REGARDING THE CURES
DATABASE. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THE COLLABORATION WITH YOU
ALL TO STRENGTHEN THE DATABASE
NEXT YEAR WE'LL HAVE SOME MORE
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
INTENTIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK. INTO THE REMOTE
VIEWING ROOM. FIFTY NINE WILL
TAKE THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WILL
BEGIN THEN WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU FOLLOWED BY SEVEN NUMBER
GLORIA. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION- I
HAVE TO ADMIT LIKE I THINK MANY
OF OR COLLEAGUES WE- WERE ALL
PRETTY SURPRISED IN THE LAST-
YOU KNOW THE LAST FEW DAYS IS
WERE REVIEWING THIS THAT. THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO BE
CONSIDERING AT THIS POINT AS
OPPOSED TO THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND- AS A- SON AND A
BROTHER OF AN ACUPUNCTURIST WHO
KNOWS HOW MANY OF THESE
BUSINESSES ARE STRUGGLING AT
THIS TIME. IT TO. IT'S
CHALLENGING- SO HAVE A QUESTION
TO THE DCA DIRECTOR IF- IF-
DIRECTOR STILL AVAILABLE. AND I
SERVE ON THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT OVERSEES DC
AND WE HAVE HAD. OUR
CONVERSATION FOR MANY YEARS
ABOUT. THE INCREDIBLE FIASCO
THAT HAS BEEN THE BREEZE
SYSTEM- DCH LICENSING SYSTEM.
OUR SYSTEM THAT. WAS INITIALLY
BUDGETED AT TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ITS RECALL.
THAT LIKE TO MANY. LARGE IT
PROJECTS IN THE STATE BALLOON
TO A NINETY SIX MILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT- LITERALLY TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BEHIND.
MANY YEARS DELAYED THERE WAS
REFERENCE MADE IN THE OPENING
COMMENTS AROUND I. T. AND MY
QUESTIONS ARE REALLY. HOW MUCH.
HAS THE CHALLENGES OF THAT
PROGRAM. REQUIRED THE FEE
INCREASES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY- BECAUSE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THAT. CONTINUE AS
CONTINUE TO REMAIN- TO BE.
RELEASED ON JAN. AND YEAH THAT.
SADDLE UP OUR- ALL OUR OUR YOU
KNOW MANY TIMES MORE BUSINESS
CAN WERE THIS IS JOHN. AND WHY
ARE WE DISCUSSING THIS IN THE
CONTEXT OF THIS COMMITTEE AS
OPPOSED TO THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS. WHERE WE COULD HAVE
BEEN DEALING WITH ALL THESE
ISSUES TOGETHER. THANK YOU A
FAMILY MEMBER TO. KIMBERLY
CLARK FIRE WITH THE CA- JUST
AT. THE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PREVIOUS SYSTEM AND WHETHER
THESE THREE ENTITIES ARE
RELATED TO THAT. SO OBVIOUSLY
IT'S A CONGLOMERATION OF ISSUES
THAT HAVE CAUSED THE- FEE
INCREASES FOR THESE BOARDS. THE
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD IN PARTICULAR
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THEM
THEY ACTUALLY ARE NOT PART OF
THE PRE SET THEM- THERE YOU ARE
GOING THROUGH WHAT IS CALLED A
WHOLE PART ONE TO OUR BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PLAN WHICH I
BELIEVE YOU'RE AWARE OF. AND SO
THEY WILL HAVE SOME COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT TO CHANGE
UP THEIR OLD SYSTEM INTO THE
NEW SYSTEM SO THEY THAT PIECE
OF IT. THE OTHER TO BOARD THE
BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES
AND- DEPORTEE AFTER MEDICAL FOR
BOTH OF THEM ARE PART OF THE
GREEK SYSTEM. BUT REALLY TO A
LOT OF THINGS INCLUDING
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION AND
BENEFIT COST INCREASES- ON
CALPERS RETIREMENT OBLIGATION
ALSO WE HAVE- ATTORNEY GENERAL
CLASS BE INCREASES AS WELL AS
THE OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE.
HEARINGS INCREASES UNTIL IT'S
ALL BEEN ALL OF THESE THINGS
ALTOGETHER THAT HAS- AS-
IMPACTED THAT AND THEN I GET A
WOULD ALSO LIKE IF MISTER PODIA
IS STILL ON THE LINE AS WELL.
BECAUSE BECAUSE PERFECT AND HOW
BUSINESS AND THEY WORK FOR HIM.
AND REALLY- WE HAVE LEARNED
FROM THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THE SENATE. APPROVED THROUGH
THE HONORED THE PROCESS AND
THEY WERE BE ROLLING OUT SOME
OF THEIR INITIAL CHANGES I
BELIEVE- AND THAT AT THE END OF
THAT SUMMER I'M FOR THAT
PARTICULAR SET UP- WHETHER I.
BELIEVE I'M STRONG. ONLINE AND
THIS WAS A ISSUE THAT WE- I'M
BETTING FOR INCREASED WITH THE-
ASSET. WE WOULD. WITH THE
INCREASE IN IT HE HAD. AT THE
GARDEN I MEAN HAPPY TO AND
ADDRESS BUT I THINK- I THINK
MIGHT BE HELPFUL IS THAT.
TYPICALLY THAT HAVEN'T GONE
THROUGH THE FACT THAT THE HUGE
FEE INCREASE THE PUBLIC ON THE
BEDROCK BUDGET PROCESS AT LEAST
IN RECENT REPORT HISTORY- WE
GET IT OUT IN THE PARTY BECAUSE
OF ITS HIGH NEED HAVE WHEN. BC
INCREASE BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO BE A NEED TO BE A
PLACE. TO STAY- RETAIN
STRUCTURAL BALANCE WITHIN THE
FUNDS- ARE RECOGNIZING THE KOBE
CHANGED A LOT OF THINGS AND A
LOT OF WAYS. ADEQUATELY THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS BUT WE
THOUGHT IT MADE NO SENSE IT
INCLUDES EVEN THE BUDGET PROFIT
FIFTY NINE I THINK GOING
FORWARD WILL HAVE TO HAVE
CONTINUE TO QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT MAKES SENSE- BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE COMMITTEE-
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER COLORADO.
WITH A CLAIM WILLING TO AND-
TAKE THIS ONE FOR US BECAUSE WE
DO THINK THAT THE FEE INCREASES
ARE NECESSARY FOR STRUCTURAL
BALANCE IN HERE. IF I COULD
JUST REPLY. TO SO I'D HEAR TO
ANSWER TO MIKE. ABOUT WHETHER.
THE FEW OF THE BREEZES WHICH
WAS AND IS BUDGET ADDED TO.
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET WHICH IS
NOW IN NINETY SIX MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET AND GOING. WHICH
STARTED I THINK IN 200-010-2000
ELEVEN AND IS STILL GOING
WHETHER THOSE COST PRESSURES
ARE IMPACTING WHY WE HAVE TO
RAISE HE'S HE'S AT THIS POINT
AND THESE ARE QUESTIONS WE'VE
BEEN ASKING. IN OUR BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FOR. FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS NOW AND HAVE NOT GOTTEN A
SATISFACTORY ANSWER THE
RELEVANCE TO THIS IS IN PART
RELATED TO THE RELEVANCE OF
THIS FUNCTIONALITY OF C. R. ET
DE SYSTEM. WHICH HAS FOR THE
BETTER PART OF A DECADE NOT
BEEN REFORMED AND WE'VE BEEN
RAISING QUESTIONS FRANKLY IT'S
BEEN A VERY FRUSTRATING
EXPERIENCE TRYING TO GET TO THE
ANSWERS OF ITSELF I HAVEN'T
HEARD ANY STRESS TODAY ABOUT
THE LINKS BETWEEN THESE BUT
WHAT I DO READ. IN THE EMAIL
SAYS IS THAT. YOU'RE A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT LICENSING. THOSE
SAME BACKLOG AT RISK OF TO BE
ADDRESS. BY EIGHTY REFORM SO. I
HAVE TO ADMIT I. I HAVE
TREMENDOUS HARPER AROUND THIS
PARTICULAR KNOWING. THE
STRUGGLING SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT. HAVE BEEN FRUSTRATED WITH
THE FAILURES OF. THE SYSTEM
HERE AND SO- ONGOING QUESTIONS-
LOOK FORWARD TO MORE ANSWERS-
IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
HERE BUT- JUST WANTED TO STATUS
FOR THE RECORD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A SIMILAR ISSUE. THIS
AMERICAN GLORIA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO. P.
BACK IN THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO A
LESS OF A QUESTION IS MORE OF A
COMMENT- AND I. ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH THE COMMENT ABOUT
YOU KNOW IT IS OFTEN NOT SEXY
TO INVEST IN INFRASTRUCTURE
PARTICULARLY IT INFRASTRUCTURE
AND OUR UNWILLINGNESS TO DO
THAT IS ON FULL DISPLAY WITH
THE DYSFUNCTION IN OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEM
NOW. AND SO THAT- THAT REQUIRES
THIS PARTICULAR ACTION TODAY
WHAT I WANT TO GET TO IS LESS
ABOUT THE VENUE ISSUE WHICH WAS
MENTIONED THE I. T. ISSUE WAS
MENTIONED WHICH IS JUST TO GET
INTO A GOOD BUDGET PRACTICES
WHICH WHEN I READ THE STAFF
REPORT I WAS MORTIFIED. WHEN
READING THAT THERE ARE FEES
HAVE NOT BEEN EXAMINED IN OVER
TWENTY YEARS THAT IS THAT IF
YOU COULD HAVE BEEN LIKE THAT
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE AND
I UNDERSTAND WHY THIS MAY HAVE
HAPPENED BUT TO THE QUESTION OF
TIMING YOU KNOW IT SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE WE'VE GOT
MANY ECONOMIC EXPANSIONS WITH
THIS WOULD MARKET IN A MORE.
APPROPRIATE TIME THIS YEAR WE.
ARE IN. FIRST TIME HAD IT. FOR
YEARS AND BASS PEOPLE TO PAY
MORE. NOW THAT MAYBE NOT. BUT I
ASKED THE MINISTRY. I THE- WHEN
WILL YOU ADOPT A FEE OF ALL
PROCESS. THAT ALLOWS THIS TO
HAPPEN ON AN ANNUAL BASIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS POSSIBLE
WHAT. WE ADJUSTED AND HAVE A
BIT OF COSCO DOWN MAYBE THEY
CAN GO DOWN AS WELL. THAT IS
PARTICULAR EFFECT IN THE MIDDLE
WHICH I APPRECIATE IN IN THE
AUTHOR TAKING. TO TAKE WHAT WAS
GOING TO BE A- IN. FEE AND MAKE
IT TWELVE IN AN- ADVENTUROUS-
LESS THAN THAT. WHICH SHOWS THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT IS IN HERE
WHICH IS WHY YOU SHOULD LOOK AT
THESE THINGS AT LEAST ANNUALLY
OR AT AT. THAT ANNUALLY IT
POPPED UP. SO HI I. APOLOGIZE
TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR TAKING A
LITTLE BIT OF GROUP THERAPY
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
BUT WHEN LOOKING AT THIS ITEM
WHICH IS PROBABLY NECESSARY
GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE
INFORMATION WOULD BE PROVIDED
IN TERMS OF. THE DIRE STRAITS
OF SOMEBODY'S FUNDS. I SIMPLY
ASK THE QUESTION WHY IS IT
TAKING TWENTY YEARS FOR ONE IN
PARTICULAR WILL HAVE TO TAKE IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE CENTS
ANOTHER ONE. AND HOW MANY MORE
OUT THERE THAT WE'RE NOT
DISCUSSING AND WE MAY BE ASKED
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IN THE
NEXT YEAR OR TWO WHEN WE KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO STRUGGLING. WITH
AT MY COLLEAGUES AND SAN
FRANCISCO MENTIONS PEOPLE ARE
PROBABLY CAPABLE THAN EVER. IN
THE SPAC OF- IT'S NOT JUST A
COUPLE OF BUCKS WHEN YOU LOOK
INTO IT ALL TOLD THESE ARE.
HUNDREDS IF NOT MORE THAN A
COUPLE THOUSAND PEOPLE. WE
SHOULD TAKE LIGHTLY AND THERE
ARE BETTER APPROACHES TO DOING
THIS TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO PAY
THIS FEE SO I WOULD OFFER SOME
STRUCTURAL FOR TO. QUESTION
GOING FORWARD. I DO BUT I. THE
NATURE WHERE THE COMING.
OBVIOUSLY THE- AND THAT IN.
INFRASTRUCTURE. MORE BORN IN A-
TO MAKE SURE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I HEARD A NUMBER OF
COMMENTS THAT I WOULD ASSUME.
THE MYSTERY WOULD LIKE TO ALL
RISK TO AT AND CLOSE BUT WILL
THEN MOVE ON TO A QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL
BEGIN WITH A SECOND WOMAN
EGGMAN FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I ALSO
DON'T. HAVE A REAL QUESTION I
JUST THINK WE'RE ALL WE'RE ALL
GRAPPLING WITH THIS THIS VERY
ISSUE- COVERT IS CERTAINLY I
THINK PULL BACK ON THE COVERS
ON A LOT OF THE DYSFUNCTION
THAT EXISTS THAT THE STATE FOR
A WHILE- AND IT'S AND WE AND
WE- DIVE INTO IT I. I JUST
WROTE A LETTER ASKING IF WE
COULD LOOK AT THE FEES JUST
BECAUSE ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS.
OKAY A VERIFY BUT HE SAID HIS
HE'S A LOCKSMITH AND HIS
LOCKSMITH BE ONE UP FROM FIFTY
DOLLARS TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
SO YEAH TO BE TO A PAIN PLAN
THEY SAID THEY WOULD STOP LOSS
CAMPUS DO THAT SO IT IS TO ME
AS WE AS EVERYONE IS STRUGGLING
TO CONTINUE TO PUSH THINGS BACK
DOWN ON THE SMALL BUSINESSES
BBS BUT IF IT WERE WRITTEN
DOUBLING DOUBLING FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN UNEMPLOYED AND
OUT NEED TO RENEW THEIR LICENSE
DOUBLING THAT THAT THAT IS TO
ME IT JUST SEEMS UNREASONABLE
TO BE ASKING THE COMMON PERSON
STRUGGLING TO STAY AFLOAT
DURING COVERT. TO PAY TO BEAR
THE COST OF THE STATE ON
INVESTING IN PLACE THAT WE
SHOULD THE BEST. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DOCUMENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'D LIKE TO JOIN MARK MY
COLLEAGUES IN ADDRESSING
CONCERN ABOUT THE VENUE. THAT
IS BEING PURSUED WITH THIS
BILL. THERE IS AN EXCELLENT
REASON WHY- FEE INCREASES ARE
GENERALLY PROCESS THROUGH THE
ACTIONS OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND THAT IS BECAUSE- WHEN. A
DEPARTMENT SAYS WE'RE NOT
TAKING IN ENOUGH MONEY WE NEED
TO RAISE OUR FEES. WE AS
LEGISLATORS HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO LOOK AT NOT ONLY WHETHER OR
NOT THEY'RE TAKING IN ENOUGH
MONEY WHICH IS HAT THIS BILL
DOES BUT ALSO TO GO OVER IN
DETAIL. HOW THEY'RE SPENDING
THEIR MONEY. MAKING SURE THAT
THE EXPENDITURES ARE REASONABLE
NECESSARY AND APPROPRIATE. AND
BALANCING THE NEED THE
DEPARTMENT AGAINST THE NEEDS OF
CONSTITUENTS THAT HAVE TO PAY
THOSE FEES. M. WORST THING THAT
STEP HERE AND TAKING
LEGISLATIVE ACTION. I MYSELF DO
NOT SEE. WHY THIS IS SO URGENT
THAT COULD NOT GO THROUGH THE
NORMAL BUDGET TWENTY FOUR
SQUARE ALSO. THE LAST WEEK WE
ASKED TO BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
WE CAN CERTAINLY PASS MORE
BUDGETARY BILLS. THE TIME THAT
WE HAVE WELL THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT. HAS NUMBER GEN BUT I FEAR
IT WILL TRYING TO. SORT OF THE
PROCESS HERE. AND I URGE POSH
IN TAKING THIS ACTION. IF WE DO.
WE'RE JUST. TO APPLIES TO. THE
TO PROCESS THE SCRUTINY COMES
WITH THE- ANTI HIS ACTION
THROUGH THIS. IN THE- WHICH I
DO THINK WOULD BE GOOD. FOR
INSTEAD OR FOR. VERY VERY MUCH
AS SOMEONE OVER TO ANY
ADDITIONAL. QUITE FOR K. AT
THIS TIME DOCTOR AFTER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVEN'T-
INITIALLY WANTED TO COMMENT ON
THIS BILL BUT I HAVEN'T HEARD
ANYONE TALK ABOUT THE CARES.
PROGRAM ITSELF WHICH I BELIEVE
IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO GROUND
OURSELVES IN WHICH IS WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR WITH THE FEE
INCREASE. THIS PROGRAMALLOWS
US TO LOOK AT A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE UTILIZATION REVIEW
AND ENFORCEMENT STRATEGIES AND
DURING THIS PANDEMIC I THINK
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR
US TO RECOGNIZE THAT SUBSTANCE
USE IS ON THE RISE. AND THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE AN
INCREASED NEED FOR US TO BE
MONITORING AND EFFECTIVELY
ENFORCING STRATEGIES. AND
BECAUSE OF THAT I DO WANT TO
THANK THE MAJORITY LEADER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL UP AND- YOU
SUPPORT. HEY SO I AM WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT THE NEED FOR A
TO HAVE THESE DISCUSS IN THE
BUDGET SETTING AS IT ALLOWS US
THE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY BECAUSE I
THINK WE HAVE A NEED DURING THE
MIDDLE OF THIS PANDEMIC. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
THE COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING A NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS PERHAPS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON IF YOU WISH TO
ALSO HAVE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
FROM ADMINISTRATION AND
RESPECTIVE AGENCIES. RESPOND AS
YOUR CLOTHES AS WELL TOO SHE
DESIRES. IF ONE OF THEM HAS
SOMETHING THEY'D LIKE TO SAY
I'M MORE THAN WELCOME THEM TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS SURE
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
MY COLLEAGUES TO HAPPEN
MINISTRATION ON THE LINE. TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND TO ANY OF THE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS I THINK
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO ALSO SEE. THAT
IT IS OUR OBLIGATION AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY ON THE
QUESTIONS OF OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY SO WITH ANY.
OTHER MEMBER OF THE- RESPECTIVE
AGENCIES WHICH TO RESPOND AT
THIS TIME. SHOULD I NEED
ARTICLE IN MOTHER CARE. GO
HEADING. I'M SORRY I'M I'LL BE
BRIEF I THINK HE'LL AND I JUST
WANTED TO NOTE THAT WE DID
INCLUDE THE FINANCIALLY AND
TRAILER BILL- SO THAT THE
QUESTIONS STARTED THERE I
TYPICALLY THAT IS NOT COMMON
FOR ATHLETES TYPICALLY THE-
TYPICALLY GO THROUGH THE POLICY
COMMITTEE PROPERTY AGAIN AT
LEAST FROM RECENT HISTORY AND
MANY OF THEM ARE TIED TO THAT-
SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS THROUGH
THOSE THOSE FEET THAT THE
AUDIT. AND THAT ARE CONDUCTED
FOR MOST OF THE FOURTH IN
EUROPE I'M NOT SURE I CAN THINK
ALL I WOULD NEED THE STATE TO
CONFIRM THAT- BUT THAT IS THE
TYPICAL PROCESS AND BUT WHEN
YOU SAY THAT THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
INCREASED FOR AND ONE CASE
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE AND
ANOTHER ONE FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS- IT IS IT DID IT THE
PROCESS AND WE TRIED TO ONLY
RAISE THAT ONE IN THERE WHEN
THERE IS AN ABSOLUTELY. BUT
THAT IS WHAT THE PUBLIC NOW
AGAIN WILLING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD
ABOUT HOW WE SHOULD APPROACH
THIS WHETHER OR NOT IT SHOULD
BE IN THE BUDGET PROCESS AND
WHEN WE USE THE PROPER THE
TWENTY HAVE CHANGED BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE AND WE DO DISCUSS
WHAT OR NOT IT AN IMPACT ON THE
TO BE BUT TYPICALLY DON'T I THE.
L. I WANTED TO OFFER THAT AND
THEN MY CHRIS RYAN FROM THE
OKAY WITH LIKE TALK ABOUT THE
TERRIBLE ABOUT. THANK AMY THANK
YOU CHAIR PRESCRIBE FROM THE OF
THE JUST JUST WANT TO ADD A FEW
MORE TO COME WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS. THE FINANCE WE AGREE
WITH COMMENT I COULD. SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS SOME OF THE ABOUT
THE SIZE OF THE INCREASE AT THE
RED LIGHT THE I. P. AND THOSE
ID CARDS I THINK SOME OF WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS THAT. THE CARD
LICENSE HAS NOT BEEN A JOY FOR
SOME. SO THERE ARE THE VERY
STRIVE RELATED TO. YOU KNOW
SALARIES AND BENEFITS AND THE
COST OF MY I. T. OVER THE LAST
DECADE INCREASING- HAVE GONE UP
AND SO- IT MAKES FOR. A LARGER
GAP AT THIS POINT IN TIME. THE
OTHER ITEM I'D JUST LIKE TO
CONTACT BRIEFLY ON. THERE WAS A
QUESTION RELATED TO OTHER IT
PROJECTS. AND I THINK THAT THIS
PROPOSAL OR THE I. DID FROM THE
UNITED. THAT IS UP AND RUNNING
BUT WHAT HAPPENS WITH THIS
SYSTEM IS THAT THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS- THAT
ARE PASSED TO BE A LEGISLATION.
AND ADDS THAT LEGISLATION IS
PASSED- WE MODIFIED THE- SO
DIFFERENT FROM BREEZE THAT WAS
REFERENCED EARLIER- WHERE
CREATING A AN ENTIRE LIFE.
THINKING SYSTEM- THEM. TEARS
HAD COME IN HANDY WHEN THEY'RE
MADE IT HAS- ADDITIONAL. NEED
FIRST ORDER- BECAUSE THERE ARE
QUITE. THE COMING FROM- THANK
THEN LONG FORTY EIGHT. AND KIND
OF A THE PANDEMIC WORSE
INCREASES WELL SO I WOULD I
WOULD BE I DO WITH IT DE
SOMEWHAT SOME OF THE OTHER BUT
PRIMARY COSTING DRIVER ARE DOES
THAT MEAN TO THE FACT THAT WE
ADDED VEHICLE ADJUSTMENT FOR
QUITE TIME THAT HAVE THE ANSWER
OTHER THAT MIGHT BE- MIGHT BE
THERE. THANK YOU FOR MUCH WILL.
TAKE THAT AS THE AS THE CLOTHES
AND FROM BACK TO THE
CONVERSATIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
BY SIMILAR GIPSON WITH AN
ADDITIONAL COMMENT AND ARE.
QUESTIONED AS SUMMER GIPSON.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR I
DO I APPRECIATE THE OFFER FOR
BRING IN HIS- HIS CAR OFF BRING
HIS BILL FOR WE CANNOT AFFORD
TO ALLOW A STATE AGENCY TO GO
UNDER AND SO I UNDERSTAND. THE
MOTIVATION BEHIND IT BUT I
WOULD CAUTION ALL THE
DEPARTMENTS INCLUDE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IF I HAD ASKED A
QUESTION I WOULD ASK THE
QUESTION INTO DEPARTMENT LINE
IS WE NEED TO FIND OUT- THAT
THIS WAS AN ISSUE- AND I WAS IN
THIS BROUGHT UP BEFORE DOING
THE BUDGET PROCESS WE COULD
HAVE BATTED OUT BASED ON.
COLLEAGUE SCOTT. THAT THEY MADE.
FAR KNOCKING ALIVE. COMMENTS
AND HOPEFULLY THAT ALL THE
DEPARTMENT IS ON THE LINE.
WATER HERE FROM THIS AND
UNDERSTANDS- THE- CAUTIONED
THAT THISBODY HAS A INVESTORS
THIS BODY OF STATE TO YOU. THAT
THIS SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN
IT SHOULD ABSOLUTELY GO TO THE
REGULAR PROCESS. THAT IS
EXTRAPOLATIONS TO GET THESE
KINDS OF THINGS OUT. THE
MESSAGE HERE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THERE'S BEEN IN MOTION AS
THEIR SECOND. SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ATTORNEY AND UP
CLOSE BY- WITH THAT AS A MEMBER
KALRA THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION APPRECIATE ALL THE
POINTS THAT WERE MADE AND ALL
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE BROUGHT
UP AND I HOPE THAT YOUR
QUESTIONS ARE ANSWERED AND I
THINK THAT IT IS ON. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ON THE
DEPARTMENTS TO PROVIDE THE
ANSWERS TO THESE QUESTIONS IN
THE IN THE THOUGHT PROCESS IT'S
ALSO ON US WHEN I SAY US I MEAN
YOU BECAUSE I WON'T BE HERE-
TWO NUMBER THAT OVERSIGHT
SOMETHING. THIS THIS BIGGER
THIS LEGISLATORS ALL ABOUT I
THINK IT'S ON US TO. STEP MORE
INTO THAT ROLE AND LOOK AT ALL
OF THESE DIFFERENT- DEPARTMENTS
IN AND MAKE SURE THAT W'RE
HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE AND IN
ASKING THESE QUESTIONS. BEFORE
I GET TO POSITION LIKE THIS BUT
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT. BECAUSE
WE ARE LOOKING AT INSOLVENCY
INSOLVENCY THAT CANNOT HAPPEN-
IRA. APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AND APPRECIATE THECHAIR IN THE
WORK. HOW TO GET THE FREE
REDUCTION FROM FOURTEEN DOLLARS
TO TWELVE DOLLARS- AND IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND IN
THIS CONVERSATION THAT. THE
AGENCY. AT THE DEPARTMENT THEY
CANNOT RAISE FEES BUT THEY CAN
REDUCE FEES SO AFTER A YEAR IF
THERE'S A- NEED TO REDUCE FEES-
SOONER THAN WE MIGHT. HAVE
EXPECTED UNDER THIS POLICY THE
DEPARTMENT CAN DO THAT BUT IT
IS ON US TO- MAKE SURE THAT WE
PASS A FEE INCREASE TODAY-
THAT. WILL HELP KEEP THIS IN
STE- THIS- THE PROGRAM FROM
GOING INSOLVENT THE FUNDING
GOING INSOLVENT. AND YET. TIME
IT'S APPROPRIATE CAN REDUCE
THAT FEE. OF A WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BOTH.
THEY YOU VERY MUCH MAJORITY
LEADER CALDERON YOU'VE- AT AN
INCREDIBLE. FOR THIS CARRYING
THE- MANTLE FOR THIS- BUT
BECAUSE WE ALSO HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF HAVING OUR BUDGET
CHAIR IN THIS COMMITTEE. WANT
TO REAFFIRM THAT THEY STICK
THIS COMMITTEE'S DESIRE TO HAVE
THIS DONE THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS. BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS
BEFORE US. IT DOES ENJOY A DO-PASS RECOMMENDATION- THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECTOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
I. KNOW I REGULAR. THE REGULAR
I. BLOOM. CHEN GENERAL JONES.
DALY DELANO EGGMAN. EGGMAN
OFFERING LARA. BERNAMA FONG.
FINAL GIPSON GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GORIN OFFERING GRAYSON. HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN- AROUND NOW
MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA HIGH
MULLIN WHAT ARE OBERNOLTE
ORIGINAL CHIANG CHING I. THE
BILL HAS SEVEN BOTH WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MAJORITY LEADER CALLED. THANK
YOU MEMBERS. CALLS WILL MOVE ON
THEN TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
REQUIRED FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THIS IS. SB SIXTY SEVEN- BY
SEVEN REQUIRE. A COLLEAGUES
THIS DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES CENTER MCGUIRE
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY.THANK
YOU SO MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- GOOD MORNING AND I
WILL BE QUICK AND APPRECIATE
THE MOTION IN THE SECOND HALF
FIRST AND FOREMOST THAT LAYS IN
GERMAN COMMITTEE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU. TO YOUR CHAIR UP FOR
ALL THIS WORK ON THIS BILL
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU VERY
CAPABLE CAPABLE STAFF IS WELL
VERY BRIEFLY SB SIXTY SEVEN IS
A TRUTH LABELING BILL- AND AS
WE SEE CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS
MARKET CONTINUE TO GROW.
CONSUMERS ARE ACTIVELY MAKING
CHOICES ABOUT THE ORIGIN OF THE
PRODUCTS THEY PURCHASED- IN SB
SIXTY SEVEN SHARES GREATER
TRANSPARENCY FOR CONSUMERS.
HERE'S WHAT THE BILL DOES IT
WILL LIMIT APPELLATIONS OF
ORIGIN TO CANNABIS IT IS PLANTS
GROUNDED OPEN AIR WOULD KNOW
OUR USE OF ARTIFICIAL LIGHT
DURING THE FLOWERING STAGE OF
CULTIVATION ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL WOULD ALSO ADD MARKING
PROTECTIONS. FOR ITS. CITY HERE
IN. FOR THE COUNTY OF ORANGE
THAT WERE TRUE GRATEFUL TO
ASSUME THE ROLE IS WELL THIS
NEVER WILL WORK WORK WITH THEIR
OF COAL OF THIS AND THE REASON
WHY WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH
THIS BILL NOW IS BECAUSE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND IS REQUIRED TO ESTABLISH A
PROCESS FOR LICENSED GROWERS TO
ESTABLISH APPELLATIONS OF
ORIGIN A CANNABIS NO LATER THAN
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE MISTER CHAIR WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR BUYER.
WE THAT THERE IS AN ADDED
ADDITIONAL- SHE WITNESSED
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF MINIMUM FOR IT WOULD YOU
PLEASE. OPEN THE LINE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT. A TERROR
CARVER IS. AVAILABLE TO DIAL IN
IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING HONORABLE
CHARACTER MANY MEMBERS MY NAME
IS TERRA CARVER I NEED
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY GROWERS
ALLIANCE REPRESENTING THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
CRACKING AN EQUITABLE AND
BALANCED BILL TO CHEAT TO BIG
PRIORITIES FOR OUR MEMBERSHIP
FIRST ESTABLISHES A BASELINE
FOR THE GROUND BREAKING
CALIFORNIA APPELLATION OF
ORIGIN PROGRAM INCENTIVIZING
THE MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY PRODUCTION METHODS
WELL HONORING A FRENCH TERM
TERROIR WHICH IS USED
EXTENSIVELY IN THE WINE
INDUSTRY. TO HIGHLIGHT THE
NATURAL ENVIRONMENTS EXPRESSION
THROUGH THE PRODUCT SECOND IS
THE ABILITY FOR PRODUCERS AND
CITIES TO PROTECT THEIR
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY THROUGH
CITY OF ORIGIN WHICH IS
CURRENTLY ONLY ENJOYED BY
COUNTY I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
IPHONE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
VALUABLE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AN ADDITIONAL KEY
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. YES THIS IS KAREN
LYING ON TOP OF THE MENDOCINO
SONOMA AND HUMBOLDT COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ALL OF THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED. IN
STRONG SUPPORT THIS MORNING OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IN ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. WE'VE GONE PAST THE
PORTION FOR KEY WITNESSES AND A
DIGITAL MEMBERS WISHING TO ADD
THEIR NAME IN THE FILIATION IN
SUPPORT. ADAM HELLO MY NAME IS
DIANE AGAIN NONE AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
NEVADA COUNTY CANNABIS ALLIANCE
BASED IN NEVADA CITY AND WE-
ARGUING ARE STRONG. WORD OF
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE MODERATOR
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB SIX
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE TO THE
EURO AT THE TIME. ENTER TO OPEN
THE LINE NUMBER ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JIM LYNCH ON
BEHALF OF THE NAPA NAPA VALLEY
VINTNERS MORE AT THE PORT OF
THE BILL. ONE ONE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MACKILLOP
ABOUT THE PLATONIC SCHOOL TO
THE BILL. NINE TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANKS HONORABLE CARE
LOAN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JENNY COLEMAN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF WORKING
HELPFUL WE OFFER A STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. NINE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SCHERING MEMBER AND THEN HE HAD
THAT IN THE PORT ON BEHALF OF
THE UNITED CANNABIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION. ONE ONE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CARE NUMBER ERROR IN ORBIT ON
BEHALF OF THE CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTION ASSOCIATION
WELCOME TRUMP SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE ONE OH TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS- THIS IS TIM SCHMELTER
REPRESENTING WINE INSTITUTE-
WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE AUTHOR
ORDERS TO REACH OUT TO THE WINE
INDUSTRY FOR OUR GUIDANCE AND
INPUT AND ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE OH EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GEN NUMBER
HAPPEN FREEMAN OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING THE STATE
BUDGET COUNTIES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. NINE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ANYTHING AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND THE
INTERNATIONAL KIND OF A FARMER
WITH A DECENT DRUNK THE PARK.
ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE THIRTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NO RESPONSE NEVER MIND
OR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THE TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS WANTED
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I HAVE
NO ONE ELSE SHOWING SUPPORT TO
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF AN OPERATOR NOW TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
OPERATOR WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB SIXTY SEVEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
LIKE THE SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
IT'D BE REAL AT THIS TIME. WELL
THE LINE ABOUT AT ONE THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE RESPONSE WILL HOLD THE LINE.
AND IT'S ONCE AGAIN IF YOU LIKE
TO SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
I HAVE NO ONE ELSE SHOP. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE DO HAVE ONE
CHRISTMAS DISPUTE UP. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE'LL
OPEN THE LINE UP TO ONE FIFTY
THREE ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. ONE ONE FIVE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
QUINCY BAIT AND I'D LIKE TO
OPPOSED S. B. ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
AS FAR AS A DIFFERENT BILL
MINIMAP GREATER ARE THERE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WE
SHOULD TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTY SEVEN. I
ALSO HAVE NO ONE ELSE SHOWING
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM OPERATOR WILL BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY FINAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEN ON
THIS BEEN IN MOTION A SECOND
SENATOR TO WISH TO CLOSE. YOU
FOR YOUR WORK WITH YOUR CHAIR
IN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER OF OUR- PLEASE TAKE
A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
SIXTY SEVEN MATCHES THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS LOW. HI WELL I
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM.
AYE CHAN CHAN I CHILL. DALY
DALY AYE EGGMAN EGGMAN BY LARA
FOR IPHONE. FONG I GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GLORIA WHERE I
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. URBANI
MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN HELLO HI OBERNOLTE ONE
OF THE I CHING. THE BILL HAS A
SINGLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTRAL VALLEY THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX THIS
IS S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR JONES THIS DOES ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION OF BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE. BIRTHDAY
BOY PLEASE PRESENT WHATEVER YOU
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND- MEMBERS IT'S AN HOOR TO
BE BACK WITH YOU ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. I AM HERE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH INCREASE
THE TRAMP TRANSPARENT. AMONG
ALL D. C. A. BOARDS AND
BUREAUS. BY RECURRING AVERAGE
APPLICATION PROCESSING TIME
FRAMES TO BE EASILY AVAILABLE-
TO APPLICANTS ON THEIR WEBSITE
ONE OF THE PROMISES OF THE
BREEZE SYSTEM MADE WAS BETTER
INFORMATION SHARING LICENSE.
APPLICANTS INCLUDING THE
ABILITY TO CHECK THE STATUS OF
AN APPLICATION BREEZE IS FAR
FROM. A FULL ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION AND DCA IS NOW
RE EVALUATING. WHETHER OR NOT
TO EVEN TRANSITION THE
REMAINING BOARDS IN YOUR OVER
TO THAT SYSTEM. IN THE MEANTIME
MANY LICENSE APPLICANTS ARE
LEFT WITH US. TO FIND OUT HOW
LONG THEY CAN BACK. TO WAIT FOR
THEIR LIVES. WITH ISN'T. ISN'T
CAESAR ABLE. TO PLAN FOR THEIR
PROFESSIONAL FUTURE IN A TIMELY
MANNER. GIVEN THE CURRENT
ECONOMIC FORECAST. FOR
APPLICANTS IT OR- TOP. TO GET
BACK TO SB EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT
ENJOY WHY VARIETY OF SUPPORT
INCLUDING THE VERY A
PROFESSIONAL LICENSEES SOCI
SHINS AND THE DCA BOARDS THAT
IT'LL- LOOK TO MAKE THESE
CHANGES OF COURSE SEVERAL
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE ALL OF
THEM AGREE THAT SHARING THIS
INFORMATION WILL PROVE USEFUL
TO APPLICANTS AND BOARDS ALIKE
MISTER CHAIR IN HONOR OF YOUR
TIME IN IN- AN EFFORT TO SPEED
THINGS UP I HAVE NOT ASKED FOR
KEY WITNESSES- BUT I DO ASK FOR
YOURS AND KIDNEYS I VOTE ON.
RIGHT A. B. SB EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR JONES. THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND SECOND WILL GO THEN
TO MEMBERS THE PUBLIC MADAM
OPERATOR WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN
UP THE OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TOSPEAK
IN SUPPORT ON S. B. EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU SIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WILL
OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHT ONE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU RIGHT VENTURE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PODIATRIC
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
LINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. THIS IS WHAT BIGELOW
HORN ON BEHALF OF THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE REMINDER IF
YOU LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NEXT OPEN LINE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. BY A JERRY DESMOND IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTY EIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSE
INVESTIGATORS THANK. I'VE KNOWN
NOW SHOWING SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME SIR PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM OPERATOR
BENHAM OPERATOR WOULD YOU I
KILEY OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. BYE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU OPPOSITION FOR SB. EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE TO OPEN MY NUMBER
ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. ONE ONE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO
I'M JENNY CLAIBORNE'S CALLING
IN OPPOSITION. ONCE AGAIN I'D
LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AT THIS TIME. AND I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE SHOWING
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
OPERATOR OF THE NUMBER IN THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. FOR ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS BUT GIVEN THAT THERE
IS A MOTION AND A SECOND WE'LL
GO WITH THAT SCRITTI SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT RESIDENTS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS LOW HI.
WELL I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I'D
BLOOM. WE BY CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
DALY EGGMAN WHEN I FOR IPHONE.
FONG I GIPSON GIPSON AYE GLORIA
GORE AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN AND I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA HIGH MULLIN. HI
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I THINK
CHENNAI. THE BILL EIGHTY. THE
BILL HAS EIGHTEEN HOPEFULLY THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS ALSO JUST WANT TO
RECOGNIZE A SIMILAR CHEN FOR
ALSO ADVOCATING SINCE STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
JONES. THANK YOU. PRESS ONE NOW
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN WHICH IS SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN. BY SENATOR DOT. SENATE
ARE WELCOME PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS. SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN SEEKS TO INCREASE THE
ACCESS TO CARE FOR CHILDBIRTH
BY ALLOWING CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES TO PRACTICE WITHOUT
THE PERMISSION OF A PHYSICIAN.
SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN PROVIDES
A WELL DELINEATED SCOPE OF
PRACTICE FOR ALL NURSE MIDWIVES
TO PRACTICE INDEPENDENTLY NO
MATTER THE CARE SETTING. SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN ESTABLISHES
A FRAMEWORK FOR EXIST FOR
PHYSICIAN NURSE MIDWIVES
COLLABORATION ON MODERATE IN
THE HIGHER RISK PATIENTS THEIR
MOOD MUTUALLY AGREED UPON
POLICIES AND PROTOCOLS. THESE
PROTOCOLS SPELL OUT HOW
INTERWETTEN DITION MIDWIVES
WILL WORK WITH PHYSICIAN
PARTNERS IN AN INTEGRATED TEAM
BASED MODE WHEN THE TRANSFER
CARE. UTILIZING THE SIDE
POLICIES AND PROTOCOLS IS A
NATIONAL NURSE MIDWIFERY
STANDARD SET FORTH BY THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF NURSE
MIDWIVES IN IS NOT SUPERVISION
LET ME REPEAT THAT UTILIZING
THE SIDE POLICIES AND PROTOCOLS
IS A NATIONAL NURSE MIDWIFERY
STATE SET FORTH. BY THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF NURSE
MIDWIVES AND IS NOT SUPERVISION.
SUPERVISION DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
ANYMORE IT'S NOT DEFINING THE
CALIFORNIA STATUTE IS DIFFICULT
TO ATTAIN IT DOES NOT REQUIRE
THE POSITION TO BE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT. EXAMINE THE PATIENT
SIDE A REVIEW IN THE CHARTS. OR
OVERSEE PATIENT CARE IN ANY WAY.
SUPERVISION ALSO FORCES NURSE
MIDWIVES TO CONCENTRATE IN
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS WHERE THE
POSITIONS PHYSICALLY PRACTICE.
THIS REDUCES ACCESS
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL COUNTIES
IN LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES
ASTONISHINGLY THERE ARE NINE
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA THEY DO
NOT HAVE. A SINLE PRACTICING
OBGYN. THERE IS A DIRECT LINK
BETWEEN RACE ACCESS IN
MATERNITY OUTCOME. ACCORDING TO
THE MARCH OF DIMES IN THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION IMPROVING
ACCESS TO NURSE MIDWIFERY
MIDWIFERY CARE. IS ONE OF THE
MOST INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES IN
ADDRESSING RACIAL DISPARITIES
IN THE DELIVERY OF A SEXUAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. ALSO I
WISH TO POINT OUT THE
CALIFORNIA IS ONLY ONE OF FOUR
STATES IN THE NATION THAT STILL
REQUIRES PHYSICIAN SUPERVISION
IN ORDER FOR NURSE MIDWIVES TO
PRACTICE. RECENT AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY TRANSFER PROTOCOLS
CODIFY THE ROLE IN MAKE UP WITH
THE NURSE MIDWIFERY ESOS-
INVITED THREE COMMITTEE IN
ADVERTORIAL THE THAT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. THE WILL HELP
DRIVE QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS IN
MATERNITY CARE. ALTOGETHER
THESE AMENDMENTS SATISFIED
REMAINING CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN A
COD. GREAT CARE WAS TAKEN TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS OF LICENSE BID
WIVES WHO WERE NOT IMPACTED IN
THIS BILL AGAIN NURSE MIDWIVES
ARE NOT IMPACTED BY THIS BILL
IN THE WAKE WHICH TODAY
REFLECTS AN APPROPRIATE BALANCE
OF SAFETY. AND ECONOMY. IN
RESPONSE TO THEIR CONCERNS THIS
BILL FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER
INCLUDES PATIENT ECONOMY
LANGUAGE THAT DOES NOT EXIST IN
ANY OTHER MIDWIFERY STATUTE.
LASTLY I'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT
WHILE SEARCHES HAVE BEEN MADE
AT THIS BILL NEWLY EXPANSIVE
PORTIONS BY MIDWIVES. IT DOES
NOT. NOTHING IN THIS BILL
CHANGES ANYTHING IN THAT AREA
AT ALL. STORY. WITH ME TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
HOLLY SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION M. NOR BE SPLIT ON
BEHALF OF THE BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS BOTH ARE CO SPONSORS
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER GOT A ONE- MADAM
OPERATOR. IF YOU COULD KINDLY
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR THE TWO.
WITNESSES A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES PER SIDE SO AGAIN- IF
FOR THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK IS
KEY WITNESSES UP TO THREE
MINUTES IN TOTAL PLEASE. FEEL
FREE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
PLANTER OPEN. HEY THERE THIS IS
HOW IT'S CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS HOLLY
PLATINUM THE HEALTH POLICY
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION I'VE SPENT
MY TWENTY YEAR NURSING WITH THE
CAREER FOCUSED ON IMPROVING
MATERNAL NEWBORN OUTCOMES IN
VARIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH ROLES
BOTH GLOBALLY AND DOMESTICALLY.
FOR THE LAST SIX YEARS MY WORK
HAS BEEN LASER FOCUSED ON
IMPROVING OUTCOMES IN
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL WOMEN IN
PERSON PEOPLE AND ALSO WITH THE
NURSES LIKE CONSULTANT TO THE
CALIFORNIA MATERNAL QUALITY
CARE COLLABORATIVE. BY NOW
YOU'RE WELL AWARE OF THE PLAN
THROUGH A STUDY SHOWING THAT
THE WELL BEING OF MOTHERS AND
BABIES AND PROVED WHEREVER
INVESTMENTS WOULD WISH FOR YOUR
MATE TO MATURITY NEW MIDDLE
THAT THE TRUMPETED MORTALITY
ARE ALL REDUCED AND AT THAT'S
PARTICULARLY IN. RURAL AND
UNDER. IT ALSO IMPROVES. YOU'VE
SEEN FOR OF A BILL TO EXPAND
THAT TO HER MIDWIFE AND- NOTE.
THAN TWO PREVIOUS TIMES.
THOUSAND SIX. I CAN TELL YOU
THIS BILL IS OUR- YET. THIS IS
A BILL THAT CONSIDERS ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. THE BILL IS NOT
ABOUT MIDWIVES GOING IT ALONE
IN FACT THIS BILL PUT
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO BALANCE
QUALITY AND SAFETY WITH
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE. AT THE
ONE TWO THREE SEVEN
INNOVATIVELY CARTS OUT
INDEPENDENT SCOPE OF PRACTICE
FOR THERE'S BEEN WIDESPREAD
REMOVES RESTRICTIVE BARRIERS
SUCH AS SUPER BIT. AND
COLLABORATIVE PRACTICE
AGREEMENTS THE OPENING UP
ACCESS WHERE THE NEED IS
GREATEST. THE BILL ALSO INJURED
THE TEAM BASED APPROACH TO CARE
FOR WOMEN AND WORKING PEOPLE
WHO NEED MEDICAL CARE. IN THOSE
CASES WITH OUR PHYSICIAN
COLLEAGUES WE CAN CONTINUE AS
WE DO NOW TO PROVIDE THE SAME
HIGH QUALITY CARE. IN EIGHTEEN
BASED MODEL WHERE DIVERSE NEEDS
ARE MET BY A DIVERSE TEAM.
GIVING HE RIGHT LEVEL OF CARE
AT THE RIGHT TIME BECAUSE THEY
KEEP HEALTH MANDATE FOR
IMPROVING OUTCOMES IN THIS
BILL. THAT I WOULD CENTER DOT
FEMALE. DISTRICT FOR WORKING
WITH A COMIC STYLE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STATES RICHER I TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. MY NAME IS NEVER
A PLAY AND I BACK IN A DIRECT
BOX COME ON ACTUALLY. WE HAVE
THE STATEWIDE BLACK OUR DAYS
AND HOW. SB THREE A BILL THAT
PARTNER BLOCKING MATTER AND I
AM A MEMBER ORGANIZATION OF ON
AND BOND ORGANIZATION A SEVERAL
I RJ. I WOULD OUR DATABASE A
DEEP AND PROTECT OKAY ALL BEEN
WILL BE ON THE ABOUT THE BLACK
WITH AND GIRLS WHICH IS WHY WE
HERE TODAY BUT MOM OF THE BABY
BUT STILL FIND UP WE WHAT KIND
OF CALIFORNIANS. SB TWELVE
THIRTY THE TOOL TO HELP BRING
THOUSAND PEOPLE EACH OF THE
DISPARITY SESSION ON. TO OUR
STATE WE ARE THE OF THE BILL
THAT EXPERIENCE RECORD ONE
OTHER CAN CARE THAT BY PAT WITH
THE FACT A LEAK A LEADER DR
BLACK CREDIT BELATED THAT. THAT
MIGHT HAVE RATES OF LOW BIRTH
WEIGHT THE ONLY BECAUSE OF
WOULD BE VERY EXPENSIVE I THINK
THERE'S A REAL OF NOT LOOKED AT
IT ABOUT IT BREAKING PEOPLE
WILL BE LEFT WITH FEWER OPTIONS
FOR KERR INCLUDING A VERY REAL.
THE HELP. THE WHAT IT IS A
VERY. BIG STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THAT WILL BENEFIT THE
OPRAH ONE THOUSAND BUT- THAT
HAPPENED STATE. A DIFFICULT
DAY. THE Y. ACTIVO. OUR PEOPLE
FROM THE ORGANIZATION.
ADVERTISEMENT B. INTEREST
BETTER H. O. R. S. B. BOB.
BAKKEN YEAH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CONCLUDES TIME A TO THE TO
KEY WE- MADAM OPERATE WOULD YOU
CAN OPEN UP LINES FOR. MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
NAME AND AFFILIATION ONLY
PLEASE IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
THE GENTLEMAN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WELL BUT MY
NUMBER ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH FROM THE-
DONE THAT BEFORE. THANK. ONE
SIXTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GEN
FORGOT BEHALF O WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
ONE ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MEMBERS WANTED TO
NARROW IT TO THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK AND ON
BEHALF OF THE HAVING OUR STATE
COALITION IN SUPPORT. LINE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THERE ARE
HELPFUL WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT AND SUPPORT. LINE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT
BENCH ON BEHALF OF BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
IS JUST NINE BOTH ASSOCIATIONS
ARE ACTUALLY NEUTRAL HONESTLY
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS FOR THE WORK WITH
US ABOUT THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL. REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT MILESTONE ISSUES TO
DISCUSS AND NEGOTIATE FOR MANY
YEARS WELL WE MY NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL SUPPORT POSITION WE'RE
STILL VERY HOPEFUL THIS BILL
WILL CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IN WORKING WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
YEAH ONE ONE SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS DOCTOR AND STORE AT SUTTER
DAVIS WOMEN'S HEALTH IN SUPPORT.
LINE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MOLLY ROQUAN THE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATE
THE CALIFORNIA IS PART. LINE
ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I THINK YOU PAY ONLY I'M
AFFECTED BY YOUR WIFE THE
WOMAN'S HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONER AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU. MY TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HIS RECTANGLE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
NURSES ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE ONE
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHEN AND HER VESTED MIRACLE
STRIP CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF
OUR TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE ONE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
YES. SEVEN I AM A NURSE AT UCSF
AND THE BIRTH WELL THEY STUDENT
NURSE MIDWIFE AND I AM IN
SUPPORT. NINE ONE FIFTY NINE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
EHRENBURG THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE ONE SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I WANT AND WE WILL
THIS NOVEMBER LONG BEFORE THE
POLICY INSTITUTE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE NINETY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DONNELLEY NURSE
MIDWIFE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ON BEHALF OF THE MIDWIFE THAT I
WORK WITH AND THE CLIENTS THAT
I SERVED IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE BY TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS BARBARA WELL I'M
UNABLE MEMBER FROM MARTINEZ AND
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S AMANDA PETERS I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
FRANCISCO AND I'M IN SUPPORT.
ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO LINE TWO
ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME THREE AND ALL THE
NURSE EDUCATOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA NELLY.
I'M IN SUPPORT. ONE ONE EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS MERRY CAPELL- RETIRED
CARDIOTHORACIC NURSE
COORDINATOR FROM HOLLYWOOD AND
I AM VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. TO
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS ELIZABETH SMITH I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE SANTA ROSA
MIDWIFERY CENTER AND BIRTH
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS REBECCA THE
TENANTS FROM A PHARMACY
TECHNICIAN AND PLANT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. TWO
TWELVE LINE IS. HANGING AROUND
I'M OFF ON A MISSION AND A
MOTHER WHO GAVE BIRTH TO MAKE
BY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. ONE NINETY NINE LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO I AND ALYSSA
JENKINS A CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES AND THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN.
A MEMORY GIVE YOU JUST WENT
ABOVE MINIMUM BECAUSE POTS FROM
A MOMENT JUST WANT TO LET THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS KNOW THAT IT
APPEARS THAT THERE A HUNDRED
AND THIRTEEN PARTICIPANTS ON
THE CALL. SO I KNOW THE NUMBER
FOR BUT JUST TO GIVE REFERENCE
FOR THE AMOUNT OF CALLS- THAT
WE HAVE ON THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
A MEMORY PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU ONE EIGHT SIX. HELP HI. I'M
I'M A REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
ADVOCATE AND STRONG SUPPORT
WITHOUT THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS CANDACE BECKERMAN
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE IN
VENTURA COUNTY AND INSTRUCT THE
PORT S. B. ONE TWO THREE SEVEN
THANK YOU. TO AFFECTS YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI CRYSTAL LOOKING
FROM A CERTIFIED NOTIFIED THAT
SATURDAY WITH WOMEN'S HEALTH IN
SUPPORT. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS B. J.
SALAM WITH BEACH CITIES
MIDWIFERY AND WOMEN'S HEALTH
CARE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
I SPEAK IN STRONG SUPPORT-
SENATE BILL ONE TWO THREE SEVEN
THANK YOU. ONE ONE HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN HOWARD ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WITH NO RESPONSE FOR MORE BONTA
OF LINE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS THERE
ANYTHING COOLER AND NURSE
MIDWIFE FOR VENTURA CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
TWO TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS KATHLEEN
BELL THERE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND I WORK IN SENATOR PRAGUE
DISTRICT I AM STRONG SUPPORT AT
THE JUSTICE AND EQUITY IN THE
TURN OF THE CHARACTER OF THE
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
TWO TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS REBECCA
WHITEHEAD NINE MONERO MEMBERS
FROM EVERY SIDE NINE POINTS
CLEAR AT TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN.
TWO THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ERIN CAME
ON AND I'M A NURSE MIDWIVES IN
DAVIS CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN
VERY. STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. TWO THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WHAT ARE YOUR MIND
OPEN HI MY NAME IS MATTHEW
POWERS I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN I'M A FIREFIGHTER
PARAMEDIC AND A FATHER AND GET
YOUR ACCOUNT. TWO THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO THREE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. HELLO YES MA'AM
OKAY MY NAME'S ELAINE BLACKETT
I CURRENTLY WORK IN GENETIC
TESTING BUT USED TO WORK FOR
HAGIA A BREAST PUMP COMPANY AND
I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN. TWO FORTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWO FOUR FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWO TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS LAURA CABANA REGISTERED
NURSE WITH SUTTER DAVIS AND
DAVIS AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. TWO TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS ANDREA RODRIGUEZ- I AM A CPA
AND MOTHER WHO HAS GIVEN BIRTH-
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF TWO
MIDWIVES AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. TWO FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES YES
MA'AM. HI MY NAME IS FOR HIGH-
I'M ACTUALLY BUT OF HEALTH AND
LIGHT UP PROFESSIONAL I HAD MY
DAUGHTER WITH A MIDWIFE I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU. TWO
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS DAISY OF BUDDY AND I
TEACH THE TRAINING COORDINATOR
NINE STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS OLIVIA
CANNELLA GARY I AM A CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIFE AND DIRECTOR OF
THE WOMEN'S HEALTHAND MARTHA.
AND I AM A STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. ONE NINETY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FIVE THE DOW YEAH
IN FACT YEAH WITH MIRACLE
WORKER CALIFORNIA AND- OAKLAND
AND I AM A PART OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. TWO FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
REBECCA GRIFFIN I WORK AT THE
FIFTY CENTER FOR GLOBAL
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AT UCSF AND
I SUPPORT TWELVE WE TALKED. TWO
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS JEAN ARIANNA NURSE
MIDWIFE AT THAT OUR DAVID'S
HOSPITAL IN DATED CALIFORNIA
AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORT. OF
THE BILL. TWO FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS ROBIN
ADAMS PLUS I'M A CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIFE WITH BETTER
MEDICAL GROUP IN DAVIS
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. TWO SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO SIX
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
LADIES GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN YOU MADE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ANOTHER
CLEAR. TWO TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWO TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WITH NO RESPONSIBLE BONTA LINE
NUMBER TWO THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS STAFFERS
SAY THAT I'M I'M A MEMBER OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN
LOS ANGELES THE CODE NINE OH
TWO FIVE I SUPPORT ALL POLICIES
THAT EXPAND REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM AND I BELIEVE THAT SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN WILL DO SO
AND I AM CALLING. SEVENTY YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. THAT'S CORRECT
TWENTY ONE AND I LOVE HER FIGHT
NURSE MIDWIFE AND WOMEN'S
HEALTH NURSE PRACTITIONER IN
CHEMICAL CALIFORNIA AND FULL
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN. TWO SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWO SEVEN TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NOT RESPONSIBLE
BOTTOM LINE TO THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THANK YOU
FOR THE HEARING THIS IS NOT MY
IS NORMA KERMIT LOW I'M A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE THE
CENTRAL. I MEAN VERY SUPPORT OF
SB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE AIRLINE OF
OPEN. TWO SIX EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS JACK I'M
CALLING FROM MENTOR. NATO BODY
WORK AND I'M IN SUPPORT. TWO
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS KATHY HEILIG
I'M A CNM IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH THIRTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL SB ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN. TWO FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL ORTIZ ON THE CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIFE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE
TWO OF THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
TWO THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MEGAN ARE
DIRTY DIRECTOR. WOMEN AND
CHILDREN SERVICES AT COMMUNITY
MEMORIAL HEALTH SYSTEM I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL WELL
THIRTY SEVEN. TWO NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
VICKY BURKE I'M A HIGH SCHOOL
MATH TEACHER OF BREASTFEEDING
ADVOCATE AND A MOTHER OF TWO
TEENAGE GIRLS AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT. TWO FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY KERRY
LAMBERT THIRTY FIVE NURSE
MIDWIFE AND NAPA AND I AM
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT AS
WELL DODD TO TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN AND AM VERY GRATEFUL TO
BE HERE TODAY THANK YOU. TWO
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS SHANTA HARD AND
I'M NOT LABOR AND DELIVERY
REGISTERED NURSE AND ALSO A
STUDENT NURSE MIDWIFE AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. AND
POLITICS THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
TWO THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS OLENA SACRAMENTO
HAINAN'S SUPPORT FOR BILL. ONE
THREE THREE SEVEN. THANK YEAH.
TWO FORTY RELIANCE OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS YOUR FAVORITE HOLIDAY
AND I'M A MEMBER WITH NAY RALPH
YOU'LL JUST GO IN AND SUPPORT
THIS BILL. TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWO FIVE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO
LINE TO FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JENNA
SHOPPER TEETH DONE I'M A NURSE
MIDWIFE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN HERE FOR TWENTY YEARS
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. TWO FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS LOIS
BE PAKISTAN I AM A CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIFE IN LOS ANGELES
AND I AM IN STOCKPORT OF SB.
ONE TWO THREE SEVEN. TWO FORTY
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS AMY I AM A ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TEACHER AND A MOM OF
TWINS AND A SINGLETON BABY AND
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT AT SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. TWO FIFTY
YOUR LIGHT IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS MARK CALLAN- A CONCERN FOR
THE SENATE AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB. ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. TWO SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TWO SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT IN A RESPONSE
TO OPEN MY TO EIGHTY TWO. TWO
EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS CAPITA
NOBLE IN THE SOUTH BAY AND
SILICON VALLEY AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT AS SB ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN THANK YOU. TO IT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS THE MAIN BETTING COURT NINE
ENABLE MEMBER FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB ONE THREE THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU. TWO THIRTY SIX
YOU'RE LOCKED UP IN. HI MY NAME
IS CHERYL TATUM AND I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND THE L. ET
AT COMMUNITY MEMORIAL HOSPITAL
IN VENTURA CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN.
TWO THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS LEE AND WEALTHY
TO MINE- I TEACH AT UCLA AND I
MY MOM AND I SUPPORT S. B. ONE
TWO THREE SEVEN THANK YOU SO
MUCH. TWO EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
THANK YOU FOR YA KNOW I'M A MOM
AT THREE AND A REGISTERED NAY.
AND MY HUSBAND. THANK YOU FOR.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES WITH
PCS IN THE AND GOT THE PART SB
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
TWO NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS A LIE AT
THE END. TWO NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
BRANDI HUTSON CANNOT I AM A
CURRENT PRACTICING I'VE BEEN P.
AND ALSO A BEGINNER STUDENT AND
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS AND- AT
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
TWO NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS DEANNA
CASTLE TEN I'M A HEALTH POLICY
PROFESSIONALS IN SACRAMENTO AND
A NEW MOM WHO RECENTLY GAVE
BIRTH COULDN'T WITH MIDWIFE
SUPPORT I SUPPORT S. B. TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. TWO NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
NANCY MEYERS FROM THE NURSE
MIDWIVES AND THE DIRECTOR OF
SAN FRANCISCO BURKE CENTER I'M
IN THE TRUNK REPORT OF ABOUT
THIRTY SEVEN. NINE THREE OH ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
SUSAN BOGART- A CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIFE FROM LOS ANGELES WITH
OVER THIRTY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THREE OH FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME'S REGINA MOORE AND
I'M AND NAY AROUND NUMBER FROM
LOS ANGELES AND I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AT TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN. THREE OR FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SHE TEAM IS ALLIE
YOUNG OF A PRACTICING NURSE
MIDWIFE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
TWO THREE SEVEN. TWO NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS. NO WILL BURN NINE
THIRTY BUT IT'S BEEN AND I
SUPPORT. THREE OH THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
CAROLINE FIVE FIND A CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIFE IN ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD JUST
REQUEST SUPPORT FOR SB ONE TWO
THREE FIVE THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER FOR THE ONE WHO LIKE
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME. MY TO
AT ONE LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS CINDY HEY I'M A LICENSED
MIDWIFE I'VE BEEN IN THE WORKS
FOR THIRTY YEARS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT S. B. ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. NINE TO TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS DENISE ELLISON
ON THE CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE
AND WOMEN'S HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONER AS WELL AS THE
DIRECTOR OF NURSE MIDWIFERY AT
TEMPLE HOSPITAL I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THREE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THREE ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS STACY
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ONE
TWO THREE SEVEN THANK YOU. TWO
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS JERRY SIGN OUR
AND THE PROFESSOR OF OBSTETRICS
AND GYNECOLOGY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND I
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. LINE THREE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
MY NAME IS LAURA I CORN I'M
APPEARING IN A REGISTERED NURSE
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
SENATE BILL ONE TWO THREE SEVEN.
THREE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BILLY ECKSTINE ON I AM A NARAL-
NUMBER AND MY HUSBAND AND I ARE
BOTH IN STRONG SUPPORT IN SB
ONE TWO THREE SEVEN. TWO SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
LAURA JIMENEZ FROM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
AT THE END OF REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AND THE MOTHER OF TWO
DAUGHTERS- WERE SUPPORTED BY
MEDICALLY SUPPORTED BY MY
REQUIRED I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL NEW CURRICULA YEAH
I THOUGHT. FORTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NO RESPONSIBLE ONE
ADELINE TO NINETY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS BORN BAG
IN THE COMMISSIONER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATUS OF WOMEN AND
GIRLS AND A POLICY FELLOW WITH
THE WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
REBECCA LEE CHET AND I'M IN A
REGISTERED NURSE CERTIFIED IN
OBSTETRICS AND ALTHOUGH A
CHAPTER LEADER FOR THE
INSTITUTIONS OF WOMEN'S HEALTH
OBSTETRIC AND NEONATAL NURSES.
I AM STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. ONE TWO THREE SEVEN THANK
YOU. THREE AFFECT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS KAREN
WORD BEHIND A MASTER'S DEGREE
AND- ASIAN AND THE NURSE THAT
ARE NEVER CURES FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS OF TACTIC THAN I THOUGHT
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWENTY
THREE SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THREE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS KAREN
SHEPHERD I AM A STUDENT NURSE
MIDWIFE AND WOMEN'S HEALTH
NURSE PRACTITIONER REGISTERED
NURSE AT GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB
ONE TWO THREE SEVEN. THREE ZERO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS GAIL PETERS I'M A
STUDENT NURSE MIDWIFE AND I
SUPPORT AT THE ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS EMILY
NO GAY HIGH SCHOOL MATH TEACHER
FROM HAPPENED A MOTHER OF TWO
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB
ONE TWO THREE SEVEN. TWO EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS MARTY HARDER AMERICA I AM A
NARAL MEMBERS FROM GREEN FELL
CALIFORNIA AND I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB. ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. THREE NINETEEN LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JIMMY
PEREIRA. FOR THIRTY THREE YEARS
AND NURSE MIDWIFE FOR TWENTY
TWO YEARS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. SB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN
THANK YOU. THREE TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS CLAUDIA WILL JUMP THEM
PARENTS OF TWIN BOYS AND I
THIRTEEN TO THE PART SB ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN THANK YOU. TWO
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BY WHERE LABOR CPA IN NAPA
CALIFORNIA AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT S. B. ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS. IS VERY I'M A NURSE
MIDWIFE IN THE HOW. AND
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
NURSE MIDWIFE ASSOCIATION AND I
STRONGLY WITH GRATITUDE WITH
THE COURT ITSELF. YEAH THANK
YOU. ONE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
MA'AM. THIS IS KATIE BOLAND I'M
A NURSE MIDWIFE. AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THREE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS KATHY
MCGOVERN I AM A NURSE MIDWIFE
WITH COMMUNICATOR HEALTH
CENTERS IN YOLO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT YOU ALL THE
VOTE YES PERSONABLE TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THREE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
SALMA HARRISON CHIEF OF
LEGISLATION WITH THE- FORTY
REGISTERED NURSING AND THE
START OF THE URGE- THE MEMBERS
APPOINTED FEEL WE HAVE. FOR IF
AMENDED THANK YOU. TWO FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS CARL GARY I'M PROCESS
IS NOT GOING TO CHANGE. AT
THIRTY AND I STRONGLY URGE.
PATTERSON IS POSSIBLE THANK YOU.
THREE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS MARTY
SAMMON I'M A CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIFE WITH TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
EXPERIENCE PRACTICING IN
ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN SO THAT ALL
WOMEN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CAN HAVE ACCESS TO A
NURSE WITH THE PRE CARE. THANK
YOU. AND AT THE TIME I SHOW NO
ONE ELSE ON SUPPORT WE HAVE ONE
MORE PERSON I JUST QUEUED UP.
LINE THREE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH PLAN AND RECORDER
AND THAT. CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIFE- IN LOS ANGELES AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT ITSELF. TWO
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWO SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM. HI MY NAME IS NATALIE
MORRIS AND I WORK AS A
RESEARCHER AT A BANK NEEDS
CHANGES IN REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
AT UC SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M A
STRONG PART OF AT THE TOP
THIRTY SEVEN. THREE THIRTY ONE.
HI MY NAME IS ALDEN CONGERAND
THE MIDDLE NUMBER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO MAYOR DUE TO SUPPORT
THAT THE TOPIC OF. THANK THREE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS NO WELL DONOFRIO I'M
A NEIGHBOR ALL MEMBERS FROM
TORRANCE CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB. ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS MARTY WILL CREATE
A LOT OF SACRAMENTO I'M NOT.
WHY AND I ALSO REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA BUT WAS HELP PROJECT
AND I. BUT. ONE TWO THREE SEVEN
SB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN. EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF
THEY'RE GOING TO GO OVER IT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR NURSE PRACTITIONERS WITH
THE PART OF THE PROPERTY THAT.
THREE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS EVAN ON
THE PASTOR IN CENTRAL ORANGE
COUNTY SERVING A CHURCH THREE
HUNDRED UNDER UNDER POPULATE
UNDER. UNDER ACCESS TO WOMEN-
I'D LIKE TO URGE YOU IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THREE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS KRISTEN BAKA I'M A
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE IN
MONTEREY CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN
STRONG SPPORT OF SB ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN. TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
BRINGING LUNCH AND I AM A
REGISTERED NURSE AND SONOMA
COUNTY CALIFORNIA BOTH IN THE-
IN THE HOSPITAL SETTING AS WELL
THE BIRTH CENTER AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. TWO EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOT. CANDACE CURLY
FROM INFLATED CALIFORNIA NURSE
MIDWIVES FOR OVER FORTY YEARS
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. ONE TWO THREE SEVEN.
THREE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS GILLIAN
OF APARTMENT AND I WAS DRUNK
THE POOR AT SB. ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. THREE FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THREE FIVE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT I DON'T
KNOW RESPOND. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THREE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS SANDRA FOR
WHEN I AM THE NARAL MEMBER FROM
REDONDO BEACH CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT S.
B. ONE TWO THREE SEVEN. THREE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME'S KAREN BUNKER KNOWN
FROM CAN'T KILL CALIFORNIA AND
I AM IN SUPPORT OF BILL. ONE
TWO THREE SEVEN. THREE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS HEATHER ROB ROY I AM-
BURBANK- DOWN HERE AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AT
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. THREE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHEN THREE THIRTY FORMULATED
OPEN HI MY NAME IS REQUIRED I'M
NOT AND BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
SB ONE TWO THREE THAT. THREE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME'S REBECCA LANDAU AND I AM
A MOTHER OF THREE AND A
LONGTIME EDUCATOR OF THE NUMBER
OF THE ROUTE. BIG SUPPORT OF
AN- AGREEMENT GOING TO SUPPORT
SAID SB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN
THANK YOU. THREE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS JEFF CORRECT I AM A
REGISTERED NURSE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO IN LABOR AND DELIVERY
AND I DELIVERED AT BIRTH CENTER
MY TWO YEAR OLD I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN AND URGE YOU TO. SUPPORT
ACOSTA. THREE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JENNIFER THIRTY AND THE NURSE
FOR BRING YOUR NURSE FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS AND AN
INTERNATIONAL BOOK BOARD
CERTIFIED LACTATION CONSULTANT
HERE IN VENTURA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AT
THE ONE TWO THREE SEVEN. I DO.
THREE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS PRINCE WORKER
FROM RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT. ONE
NINE THREE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THREE TWENTY
THREE YEAR ITSELF. NO RESPONSE
THE OPEN LINE THREE FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FINALLY ON.
A LEDGE VENTURA CALIFORNIA BUT
ON THE THIRD ALSO CAN BE LISTED
ABOVE. WITHOUT THIRTY FIVE
MINUTES WIDE IN A PHONE SUPPORT
AT ONE OFTEN YEAH. THREE TWENTY
ONE LINE IS A- HI MY NAME IS
GAIL NECKLINE OAK PARK HELD I
TO DAUGHTERS I'M IN THE WRONG
NUMBER AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN.
THREE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I ALREADY SPOKE WITH
MISTAKES PUT MYSELF BACK IN
QUEUE THANK YOU. TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN I NAMES
TRUE AND BELL THERE MY MOTHER
IS THE PACKING UP THE END OF
MAY AND I AM INSTRUCTS THE
BOARD SB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN.
THANK THREE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS EVE
GORDON I'M A LONG TIME NARAL
MEMBER FROM VALLEY GLEN LOS
ANGELES IN A MOTHER OF TWO
DAUGHTERS THEY- YOUR SUPPORT
FOR AT. TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN.
THREE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME'S EVAN WRAPS
I'M A CONCERNED CITIZEN FROM
ALLSTATE CALIFORNIA MY MOTHER
IS A MIDWIFE AND I'M CALLING TO
STRONGLY URGE THAT YOU SUPPORT
S. B. TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN THANK.
AND A REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SHOW SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ACTIVE TIME THREE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN
YES MY NAME'S JERRY GOLDSMITH I
MODIFIED TRANSITION FROM SANTA
CLARA COUNTY I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF- SB AT TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWO NINETY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LATE WE'VE ABOUT ME
AND I SUPPORT AT THE ONE THREE
SEVEN. ONE TWO THREE THAT BUT.
ONE THREE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS AMANDA
WALL I'M A STUDENT NURSE
MIDWIFE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA AND I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT AT TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
SORRY MY NAME IS MICHELLE A
MINIMUM NAY ROUTE MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN DIEGO AND I HEARD YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. THREE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS SOPHIA
DELIVERED A TWENTY I'M IN THE
WRONG NUMBER FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND I AM ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AT. TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN. THREE SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THREE SEVEN SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS HALEY OF
HARDIN I AM A NEIGHBOR ALL
MEMBER OPENED CALIFORNIA AND I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. THREE SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS HANNAH CAMMARATA I'M A
NONMEMBER FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND I HEARD YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. THREE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS LISA CALLING AND
I'M AND I WILL MEMBERS FROM LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR S. B. ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN. THANK YOU. THREE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME TWENTY FOUR GAS AND
THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD AND I'M CALLING IN TO
SUPPORT- ITEM SB. ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WITH A NUMBER. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
GERRY COHEN I AM A FATHER OF A
BABY BORN AT A GOOD WIFE
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA RUN. AT THE
PORT. SB. TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN.
THREE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE ATTORNEY MY THREE FIFTY
THREE IS THAT WRONG. BLIGHTED
OPENING PROVIDE. YES MY NAME IS
LYNN MICHELADA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AFTER THE TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN. I'M FROM VENTURA
CALIFORNIA. AT THE TIME I SHOW
KNOWING ALL SHOWING SUPPORT
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM OPERATOR THAT
CONCLUDES THE PORTION OF OUR
HEARING FOR MEMBERS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT WILL NOW GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC QUESTION.
BY AN OPPOSITION WILL ALLOW FOR
A TOTAL OF UP TO THREE MINUTES
FOR KEY WITNESSES WHICH IN THIS.
AT I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE TWO
WITNESS BATUM OPERATOR WOULD
YOU KINDLY UP THE PORTION OF
THE MEETING FOR THE TWO KEY
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL.
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. THEY'RE
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS THERESA YOU
AND ON THE BOARD PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES FOR ACCESS
TO MIDWIFERY A CONSUMER
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION WITH OVER
FIVE THOUSAND SUPPORTERS. TODAY
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OVER
TO ORGANIZATIONS AND GROUPS WHO
OPPOSE SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ARE LICENSED
MIDWIFE. WHICH REPRESENTS OVER
FIVE HUNDRED LICENSED MIDWIFE
IN THE STATE AND CONSUMER
ADVOCACY AND BIRTH PROFESSIONAL
GROUPS. AND PRACTICES. WE
BELIEVE AN ADVOCATE FOR BIRTH
JUSTICE RACIAL JUSTICE AND
REPRODUCTIVE AUTONOMY
UNFORTUNATELY SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO LONGER SUPPORTS THE
PRINCIPLES. WE STAND FOR THIS
BILL HELLO A LIVE THE VALUES.
AND EVAN BASED BIRTH
RESTRICTIONS IN THE BILL JUST.
AND BLACK AND INDIGENOUS OUR
COMMUNITY COLOR. THE PAY A
COMPANY LINKED IS AN ADDED AND
THE PATIENT. LANGUAGE
INADEQUATE AND STILL. AND FOR.
OF CARE. IN THE DATA NOW A
SINGLE THAT ROUND AND ETHNICITY
IS REQUIRED. AS AGREED BY OUR
COALITION. I WOULD LIKE TO READ
YOU A STATEMENT FROM BLACK LED
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING OAKLAND
BETTER BIRTH FOUNDATION ANYA
HEALING CENTER FOR BIRTH AND
FAMILY LIFE. IT IS ALSO FINE BY
THE CO FOUNDER OF BLACK WOMEN
BIRTHING JUSTICE. ANALYSTS OF
LATE BIRTH. AMONG OTHERS SERVE.
UNDERSERVED POPULATION. I
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN AM ONE
NEGATIVE AND THE BLACK ENDED
AND MIDWIVES OF COLOR WHO ARE
CURRENTLY TRAINING. OR WILL
TRAIN IN THE FUTURE TO ANSWER
THEIR CALLING. TO CARE FOR
THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES ACT
COMMITTEE FREE AS YOU IS LADEN
WITH BOTH CLOSE AND THAT. THE
AMOUNT OF EDUCATION AND SOCIAL
SUPPORTS REQUIRED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. MAKE MIDWIFERY
EDUCATION DIFFICULT TO
PERSPECTIVE. AS AN ADVANCED
PRACTICE NURSING DEGREE
ULTIMATELY PROGRAM TOLD.
THOUSAND DOLLAR IN CUMULATIVE
KEISHA KA. I THINK SB TWELVE
THERE SEVEN AS WE- TRANSLATING
YEARS BY TRAINING TO BECOME A
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER ONLY TO
HAVE. LUNCH PRACTICAL TOWARD
EAST I NEED THE SOCIAL TO OF
RAINFALL UNBIASED MEAN THAT IT
IS LEFT MY BLACK INDIGENOUS AND
THE COLOR THAT CAME. FROM
POSITIONS ON THIRD. THE VIEW
THE AS PROFESSIONAL COME. THOSE
IN THE FOR DO NOT SUFFER THE
SPENDING. THERE NURSE MIDWIVES
DESERVE A BELT THAT HOLLYWOOD
FRANKLIN AS LEADING PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS AND CHANGE
MAKERS. IN THE SIDE OF
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE. AGAINST
BLACK MATERNAL AND INFANT
MORTALITY A BILL THAT CENTERS
THE 6% OF BLACK WORKING PEOPLE
1% OF INDIGENOUS BIRTHING
PEOPLE AND POINT 4% OF PACIFIC
ISLANDER PERSON PEOPLE. WHO ARE
HAVING THE WORST OUTCOME IN THE
STATE. I THANK YOUNG THE
EXPERIENCES THE WORST. AND THE
MIDDLE WHO ARE AT RISK OF THE
COMMUNE. THAN OPERATING PEOPLE
MADE BY AND- IN THE STATE
PROSPER. NOT THE OUTCOMES AND
DRIVING COMMUNITY BENEFIT ALL
PEOPLE. CALIFORNIANS DESERVE. A
MIDWEST RETAIL THAT DOES NOT
PROVIDE NURSE MIDWIVES FREEDOM
FROM PHYSICIAN SUPERVISION AT A
COST THAT WILL BE PAID BY THE
PEOPLE WHO CHOOSE TO SEEK THEIR
CARE. AND SOME OF THE
SUPPORTING OF THE OPPOSING
ORGANIZATIONS. FOR SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN AND COULD I COME
BACK FACT. CALIFORNIA'S
CALIFORNIANS EXAMPLE DOESN'T
MAKE THE FREE. COM CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COLLECTIVE MADE
LIGHT BURKE STREAMING WITH
RESERVISTS THIS BIG RALLY
MIDWIVES HERO BIRTH SERVICES
BETTER PRECISION OF HARLEM NEW
YORK MAN CENTER FOR BIRTH AND
FAMILY LIFE. BURKE MIDWIFERY.
LONG BEACH BIRTH RECORD OF CALL
COLLECT THE MIDWIFE BIRTHING
WITH FEAR. WITH THE LABOR BURKE.
THE OAKLAND BETTER BIRTH
FOUNDING. AND. ICON WELCOME
HOME COMMUNITY BIRTH CENTER AND
FORMER FAMILY WELLNESS AND
PERCENTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES THE PORTION OF THE
MEETING FOR KEY WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION BUT NOW
MOVE ON TO THE PORTION OF THE
MEETING FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SIGNIFY THEIR
OPPOSITION WITH NAME AND
AFFILIATION ONLY MADAM OPERATOR
WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN UP THE
LINES TO ALLOW FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. I'M AN AFFILIATION
THANK YOU. HI LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY DIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE RESPONSIBLE BONTA
LINE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR LINE
TWENTY FOUR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO. MY TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES
MA'AM. THIS IS THE MARQUEE WILL
OPEN AND I'M QUITE CALIFORNIA-
SACRAMENTO AREA I'M THINKING.
THIRTY FIVE THE QUESTION A
MIDWIFE AND I AM CALLING YOU
SUPPORT AN ACCOUNT WITH ME SB.
ONE THREE THREE SEVEN. RIGHT
NEXT DOOR TO LINE A ONE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK.
HI MY NAME IS REBECCA AND I AM
A FULL SPECTRUM DOULA OF THIRTY
PLUS YEARS AND OUTREACH
DIRECTOR GROUP OF LABOR BIRTH
COLLECTIVE MY PARTNER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE S. THIRTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. HELLO TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. VERY WELL
MOTHER OF TWO YOUNG OPPOSE SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. MACULATA
LINE THREE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
WELL I HAD. HI DAVID BRAND
LATER I MEAN MOTHER A MIDWIFERY
CONSUMER AND A CHILDBIRTH
EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. NEXT
SELECT ONLINE ONE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE SIX
THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YOU MAY BE NEEDED ON YOUR END.
CONNECT A MULTILINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. YES YOU CAN HEAR
GREAT THANK YOU MY NAME SHANNON
LAUGH AND THE MIDWIFERY
CONSUMER AND- PROFESSOR CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. MAXIMO
TIMELINE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YOU MAY BE NEEDED. YES WE CAN
AREA YES THANK YOU- MY NAME THE
SUN FIRE MORGAN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF OAKLAND BETTER
BURKE FOUNDATION I AM A MOTHER
AND GRANDMOTHER RESIDING IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA VERY MUCH
SUPPORT COMPLETED HARMONY FOR
NURSING WIVES THAT WE CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL ONE AT ONE
THIRTY. CAN. NINE ONE NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MAXIMO
COULD THREE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD.HI MY NAME'S AMANDA
KAGA AND I AM A MIDWIFERY
CONSUMER AND EIGHT- UCSF
CHAPLAIN AND FORMER CHAPLAIN IN
THE BIRTH CENTER AT UCSF
BENIOFF CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL SB
ONE TWO THREE SEVEN. MADTOM P.
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN HELLO.
YES HE CAN AREA. OKAY MY NAME
IS ALINA HAMRICK I'M A
CALIFORNIA LICENSE AND WHY AND
I HAVE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
UNLESS IT'S AMENDED TO PROTECT
PATIENT MEDICAL SERVICE. ASIAN
AND NURSE MIDWIVES A COMMON
INCOME OF DECISION. ALL OF THE
COMMISSION. MAXIMO TO LINE ONE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OR
SHOULD BAKER I OPPOSE SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. MAXIMO TIMELINE
TWO SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINETY THREE B. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MANY MORE INTEREST AND
I'M THE MOTHER OF THE BABY BORN
AT HOME TO THE CARE OF HIS
WIFE. AT AGE FORTY SEVEN IF IT
DOES NOT LOOK FAR DIFFERENT
LIVE WITH RECONFIRM. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YOU MAY BE NEEDED.
CONNECT THE MOTEL NINE ONE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS PATRICK CALDWELL AND
THE FAMILIES THE CONSUMER OF-
MIDWIFERY SERVICES EXTRA ONLY
OPPOSED THE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY SIX. HI MY NAME IS
PAULA BARBER I AM A NEW MOTHER
WHO GAVE BIRTH AT HOME WHICH
SUPPORT WIFE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY THIRTY.
ONE MY THIRTY OTHER. THANK YOU
ALDERMAN YOU LOVE REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE ADVOCATE WITH REPUBLIC
REFLECTIVE AND I VERY STRONGLY
OPPOSE WELL. THREE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. STRIDER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR RIGHT TO LIFE OF KERN
COUNTY CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LIKE
THAT THE KIDS THE KERN COUNTY
IN OPPOSITION TO ESCAPE ONE
THAT. THREE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS AMIT
ALLAH AND I AM AND THEY WENT
CONSUMER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. ONE OH SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS YOUR
RHONDA. CALIFORNIA LIFE GOOD
WHY OPPOSING SB. ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CAITLYN
ACCURATE AND I AM MIDWIFERY
CONSUMER HAD MAYBE GET BACK
HOME MIDWIFERY CARE AND I
OPPOSE THIS. ONE TWO. MY TWO
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY TWO SEVENTY NINE OUR BRAVE
YOUNG. HI MY NAME IS WORKING ON
AND I WAS NOT GIVEN A NUMBER
SORRY I'M CALLING IN OPPOSITION
SB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN THANK
YOU SO MUCH. LINE EIGHT LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS NICOLE
REGIONALLY- BEHALF OF BAY AREA
BIRTH INFORMATION AND WHILE I
AGREE FULLY WITH THE PROMISE OF
THE BILL I CANNOT- SUPPORT
UNLESS- CNN INTERCHANGE SO I
OPPOSE THE LAST MINUTE. THREE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THIS LUXURY TWELVE WHOSE
SUSPECTS SEVEN I DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT IT WOULD BE AND MEDICAL
INTEREST. I WAS SUPER
BRIDGEPORT A MAXIMUM PROCEDURE
OKAY FOR DEMONSTRABLE. THANK
YOU. LINE THIRTY TWO YEAR IS
OPEN. LINE THIRTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOU MAY BE MUTED. NO
RESPONSIBLE ONE TWO ONE ONE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY SHE LET HERSELF IN
Q. ONE ONE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JOE
BUCHANAN BUT I'M A FULL
SPECTRUM DOULA AND I'M-
SPEAKING ON OF THE. THAT OUR
FIRST THROUGH LABOR COLLECT ICE
A- THE ONE TWO SEVEN IT DOES
NOT GRANT MADE BLACK TANYA
PRACTICE AND IT DOES NOT ON
APPROVING PEOPLE FOR ME WE
CANNOT HAVE THIS IT IS. THANK.
ONE THIRTY FOUR. HI MY NAME. I
AM THE DILLON THE LOS ANGELES
AREA PROBLEM MOTHER AT THE OF.
FOR THE ADVANCEMENT OF MEN WITH
I ONLY OPPOSE THE BILL TWELVE
THIRTY AS IT DID NOT GRAB
KANEMI FOR THE BIRTHING PERSON
OR- HI. LINE ONE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS TERESA AFFE I HAVE- AS A
MIDWIFE PROVIDE SERVICES I
SUPPORT INDEPENDENCE BUT THIS
ISN'T THE BY BILL. SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO ONE
SEVEN HIGHLIGHTED. I I'M ON AN
OPEN. RETIREMENT PARKER KERR
MOMENT. COMMUNICATION DIRECTOR
FOR REPLACE BERKELEY AND
PONDERED THE BEAR CORPORATE
MONTHS BUT DOING TRAINING
TRAINER AND. HELLO SAID KNOWING
FOR TURN THIS BILL THAT LIMITS
THE CANNOT COMMENT CALLED
EXPECTS THE MOST MARGIN. OF
COMPOUND IN. ONE NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIVE ONE ONE
ZERO I AM QUEER ASIAN BIRTH
WORKER LIVING IN WE CANNOT LET
ME LAND THIS IS OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I AM SUPPORTING.
BETTER BETTER OUTCOMES ACROSS
THE BAY AREA- OR THE PROCTER OF
MIDWIFERY AND- NURSING. I DO
NOT SUPPORT I THREE ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN AS IT IS WRITTEN. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. FOUR
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SO FAR
I'M A LICENSED MIDWIFE AND
ABOUT CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THE BILL ON THREATENS
THE ECONOMY ABOUT NURSE MIDWIFE
AND BURSTING PEOPLE. TWO ZERO
NINE YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
CHILLING NINE NINE AT A HOME
BIRTH WITH A MIDWIFE AYE
OPPOSED. FOR NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FOUR NINE. YES ROSANNA
DAVIS WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSED
MIDWIVES REPRESENTING FIVE
HUNDRED PLUS COMMUNITY MIDWIVES
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL- SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN FOR AGREE JUST
RESTRICTIONS ON ACCESS. THIS
BILL ACTUALLY PUT IN PLACE.
FOUR TWENTY AIRLINERS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS TANYA CRACKIN I'M A
LICENSED MIDWIFE MONEY BACK
MAMA I'M A TWIN MAMA AND I
OPPOSE SB TWELVE THIRTY THAT.
FOUR SEVENTY NINE ELEVEN. HI MY
NAME IS KURT ALDER I AM PARTNER
TO A BIRTH WORKER DO WELL AND
SPROUT DOUBT ABOUT THE WITH
LIBERTY YEP ON THE AND WHAT AND
CHILDREN ABOUT STERN NOW TO THE
BILL THANKS. ONE SIXTY NINE
MINUTE OPEN. SIX NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NO RESPONSIBLE ONE TO
TWO SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LET ME YES MA'AM. TWO SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOR MY
RETURN YOUNG WILL END IN FIVE
MINUTES. AND I'M A BIGGER THEME
THERAPY MOTHER BURKE PARKER IN
THE BAY AREA AND I OPPOSE BUT A
BILL. TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. FOUR
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FOUR TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HOW DO I AM ON THE FIRING
MIDWIFE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS IT WILL NOT ALLOW
THE AND THEN TO HAVE THE FULL
PRACTICE AUTHORITY AND I AM
VERY EXCITED. FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE ABOUT. FOUR TWO NINE NINE
ONE ONE UNOPPOSED. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW OPPOSITION
FOR SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
MA'AM. HI MY NAME IS MADELEINE
WISLER I'M A LICENSED MIDWIFE
AND I SPECIALIZE IN MIDWIFERY
ACCESS FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL ALSO A
PREGNANT MOTHER REALLY STRONG
OPPOSED WITHOUT. ONE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS FELIX KJELLBERG
CALIFORNIA LICENSED MIDWIFE AND
CO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. OF THE
CLINIC AND TRAINING AND I THIS
BILL THE BILL SB ONE TWO THREE
AS A IS CLEAR WRITTEN. THANK
YOU. NINE EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME TO FEEDBACK OF CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YEAH HI I WANTED TO
OPPOSED SENATE BILL ONE TWO
THREE FIVE AND I'M ALEXIS
CALIFORNIA AND I FEEL IT'S
RESTRICTIVE. FOR TEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS KOBE-
BE HOOKED FATHER THAN A HUSBAND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN AT THE DOES NOT
GRANT A ON TO ME FOR MY- ADVICE
IN THE BEAUTIFUL. IT WILL BE.
IN THE WRONG DIRECTION I
THOUGHT. SIXTY FIVE YEAR LINE
AND. HI MY NAME IS A KEY OR
BLACK MORE AND THEY HAVE MADE
BACK HOME. ONE TWO THREE.
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE ITSELF.
HI MY NAME IS REPEAT. I BUT AND
I. ONE TWO THREE SEVEN. THREE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
SANDRA CALIFORNIA LICENSE PLATE
LIGHT ENGINE MUCH TERRITORY
OFTEN OUT OF SANTA BARBARA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. FORTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS KATIE
BOLAN NURSE MIDWIFE FOR THIRTY
SIX YEARS DOING HOME BIRTH. AND
THIS LAW. I HAVE I OPPOSE IT AS
WRITTEN WILL REACH PRACTICE
WITH NINE CIVIC EVIDENT. FOR
EIGHTEEN LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS DONNA CASTUS I AM A
CONCERNED CITIZEN AYE OPPOSED
SB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN THANK
YOU CONFERENCE WILL END IN ONE
MINUTE. THERE ARE WORLD IN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
JOHN BELCHER I'M A SURGEON AT
THEIR PROCESS BUT I'M SORRY I
WAS IN SURGERY I JUST GOT OUT
TO MAKE MY COMMENT. SO FORGET
IN LATE STRONG SUPPORT BILL I
SUPPORT THIS I DO NOT OPPOSEIT
I JUST WANNA MAKE THAT CLEAR.
THIS BILL TAKEN ACCOUNT PATIENT
AND MIDWIFERY OPTANTE INSURANCE.
AND QUALITY VERY MUCH MADAM.
COULD CONTINUE TO THE NEXT
CALLER. TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FOR TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NOT RESPONSIBLE
ONE TWO ONE FOUR OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MARC I AND II
I JUST GRADUATED FROM UC DAVIS
OF THE PERSON WHO INTRODUCED
THE BILL. IS MY REPRESENTATIVE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. THE
BAIL- SB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN
BECAUSE IT RESTRICTED FONG.
WITHOUT YEAH I'VE BEEN IN AND
FURTHER EXAM YOU VERY MUCH MARK
CAN GET KILEY CONTINUE AND JUST
TO REFERENCES BECAUSE I KNOW I
BELIEVE THAT THEIR NUMBER OF
CALL OR JUST YES NOW THAT WE
ARE FORTUNATE MEETING JUST FOR
NAY IF YOU CAN AND SHOULD NOT
THREE HUNDRED ENDING NOW. YEAH.
AT A MODERATE IF YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE ON DILIGENTLY
AS YOU HAVE BEEN DOING. WE ARE
NOT THE PORTION OF THE MEETING
FOR MEMBERS. PUBLIC WISHING TO.
STATE THEIR OPPOSITION.
VENTILATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO. AND GOD COLLEAGUES TO UP
THAT THERE MIGHT BE A TECHNICAL
ISSUE AT THIS PARTICULAR MOMENT
COULD JUST STAND BY PATIENTLY.
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO TRY TO GET
THE COLORS.
AND WHILE WE ARE
STILL CONVENE I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE GALLERY WISHING. TO
TESTIFY AND GIVEN THAT WE ARE
STILL TRYING TO WAIT ON SOME
OTHER TECHNICAL ISSUES THE
MEMBER. PUBLIC WHICH IS TO
TESTIFY IS AGAIN ON THE S. B.
TWELVE SEVEN POSITION. WHENEVER
RIGHT. GREAT MY NAME GREG BIRD.
FOR WE CAN ALL OF LEVEL. WE ARE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED BECAUSE
THE BILL LOWERS HEALTH
STANDARDS FOR WOMEN AND EXPANDS
THE NUMBER OF SURGICAL AND
MEDICAL ABORTIONS THANK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS IN THE GALLERY WISHING
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALSO FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
OKAY.
OKAY ARE COLLEAGUES I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE LINE IS NOW
BACK ON LIFE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. SO JUST A TO
HELP VERIFY. MADAM OPERATOR I.
FAM THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS
SO- WILL GO BACK THEN. AND
AGAIN FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO ARE JUST TUNING IN WE HAD A
BIT OF TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
AND WILL NOW GET BACK TO.
PORTION OF THE MEETING WHERE
THE PUBLIC WILL TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN S. B. TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
CENTER DOT. ADAM OPERATOR WOULD
YOU CUT OPEN THE LINES TO ALLOW
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SIMPLY STATE
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
A PORTION OF THE MEETING FOR
MEMBERS WILL TESTIFY KNOBS. AND
NAMES AND OF ASIANS ONLY.
SORRY
ABOUT THAT I AM WITH HERO. OKAY.
BECAUSE OF THE- NO MORE
TECHNICAL TO THE PEOPLE OF
CHINA WERE FREE FROM YOU KNOW
LIKE A GREAT TWENTY OPERATOR I
AM STILL HERE IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT WHILE BACKED UP PARTISAN.
NO THANK YOU. THANK.
NO PROBLEM
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
ONCE AGAIN THIS IS EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR WE DO HAVE
PARTICIPANTS JOINING WE SHOULD
BE READY WHATEVER YOU'RE READY
TO GET STARTED AGAIN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM OPERATOR AGAIN
WE APPRECIATE YOUR DILIGENCE.
WE WILL NOW BE IN AGAIN MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WE'RE NOW THE
PORTION OF MEETING FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER WHICH IS S. B.
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
DOT. MADAM OPERATE WOULD YOU
KINDLY OPEN THE LINES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SIGNIFY THEIR OPPOSITION
WITH NAME IN RELATION ON. THANK
YOU IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME.
IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS STAR
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. LET
ME JUST ONE MOMENT FOR FIRST
LINE. I NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONLINE NAME IS NIKKI AND
GET ACT AND I'M A FULL SPECTRUM
DOULA CAN SOUND GLASS AND I AM
STRONG OPPOSITION OF S. B.
WELL. THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
LINE ONE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND ONE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN AREA PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JENNY
PAGEL AND I'M OPPOSED. THANK
YOUR WALLMARK TO LINE ONE OH
FOUR ONE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LEVINE LEVINE ONE OF
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AMY ADAMS
AND THE STUDENT MIDWIFE WITH
WELCOME HOME COMMUNITY BIRTH
CENTER AND BOAT I CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER LINE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
OPERATOR JUST FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THOSE WHO MAYBE. STILL
HAVEN'T HAD OPPORTUNITY CALLED
WOULD YOU TRY ONE MORE TIME
AGAIN FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS THE STAR AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND OVER A
WHITE NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE NINETY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN. THANK YOU. SHE. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MORE MOMENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS. THE STAR AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME.
PROVIDE ONE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO. YEAH I'M TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I SHOULD
BE MORE THAN TWICE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA NINE BILLS. SECURITY
ONE MORE MOMENT FOR NEXT ONE.
AS A REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO
SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
STAR AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WILL PROVIDE A ONE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
BRANDON CURRENT I LIVE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I.
THANK YOU ENACT OVER TO ALIGN
ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I HAVE NO MORE LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MA'AM OPERATOR WE
WANTED TO PROVIDE AN ABUNDANCE
OF CAUTION TO ALLOW FOR OTHER
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
SHOULD THEY NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO TESTIFIED EARLIER. NOW THAT
WE'VE LOST THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. WILL NOW
BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE- FOR
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS TO ALSO NOTE THAT
THERE IT'S ALREADY BEEN A
MOTION AND SECOND AGAIN MEMBERS
OF COMMITTEE SKINNER. IS ARE.
AND WILL BE WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE. CHEMIST THERE
IS. ARE OF THE BILL. INCLUDED
LETTERS OF OPPOSITION FROM. THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL HE
CALIFORNIA PROLIFE COUNCIL THE
CALIFORNIA RIGHT TO LIFE
COMMITTEE AND CALIFORNIANS FOR
LIFE. ARE MAKING THE ASSERTION
THAT THAT THIS BILL. GRAHAM'S
MIDWIVES THE OPPORTUNITY OR THE
ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN OF
TIONS. THAT THEY DID NOT
PREVIOUSLY HAVE. THE CHECK
AUTHOR OF THE BILL IS TESTIFIED
THAT THAT IS NOT THE CASE- MY
CAREFUL READING OF THE BILL I
DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING ABOUT THAT
IN THERE BUT I NOTICED A HAD.
SOME TESTIMONY CAL FAMILY
THAT'S WHAT I WONDER THE- HERE
AND TELL US UP AND WEBER. WELL
HE BELIEVES SIX AND ACCESS TO
AVOID. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ULTI OF AN- I
BELIEVE THAT INDIVIDUAL WAS IN
THE GALLERY UNFORTUNATELY I
DON'T SEE THAT INDIVIDUAL IN
THE GALLERY AT THIS TIME- SO-
PERHAPS THE THAT MIGHT BE
RESERVED FOR ANY CLOSE COMMENTS
AS WELL TO BE ABLE TO DRESS IT.
I TAKE THAT THAT- ASSERTION
VERY SERIOUSLY BUT MY READING
OF THE BILL I DID NOT REVEAL TO
ME. ANY TRUTH TO THAT SO I'D BE
VERY INTERESTED IN THAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AS A MEMBER OLDER
OBERNOLTE. ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC-
COMMITTEES WISHING TO SPEAK AT
THIS TIME SEEING NONE SENATOR
DODD DO WISH TO CLOSE. YES
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS FOR. A CITY THROUGH
THAT RIGOROUS DEBATE- AND ALSO
WAS YESES AND NOS. I REALLY
WANT TO THANK THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION. UP IN THE
A COPY. FOR COOPER. IN GET US
TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY. AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE MOST
DEDICATED- CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES WHO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE. COMPROMISE IN THEIR
TENACIOUS EFFORTS. TO WHAT I'VE
COME TO WHERE WE ARE AT TODAY
AND ALSO TO YOUR COLLEAGUE. AND
I REMEMBER SITTING ON THE FLOOR
AS- IS DISAPPOINTMENT AND- ALL
BURKE AS REALLY CHAMPION THIS
WILDLIFE LIKE I. YOU'RE A GOOD.
THAT SHE WILL HAS THE YOU IN
YEAR OUT AND I APPRECIATE HER
INCREDIBLE SUPPORT- ON THIS
BILL. WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THE RIVALS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER DOG A COMMENSURATE
WITH THE CONVERSATION THAT YOU
AND I HAVE ALSO HAD THAT THIS'S
BEEN ONGOING. ISSUE THAT WE'VE
ATTEMPTED TO TACKLE WITH
VARIOUS ITERATIONS BUT- WANT TO
KNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF YOUR
COMMITTEE YOUR STAFF. AS WELL
AS A YOURSELF TO HELPING
SHEPHERD THIS THROUGH AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS IN PLACE
AS YOU CAN SEE THERE'S A WIDE
VARIETY OF OPINION- BUT-
PLEASE. OUR STAFF HAS ALSO BEEN
DEDICATED TO WORK WITH YOU AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO IS THIS.
TRUE HOPEFULLY MOVES FORWARD-
THIS DOES ENJOY A AYE
RECOMMENDATION THAT WOULD BE
HONORED IF YOU WOULD ADMIT
AUTHOR SHOULD I'M- OKAY
COMMITTEE SICK. WOULD YOU. ROLL
SB TWELVE THERE IS A RESIDENT
MOTIONS TO PASTOR PER LOW HIGH
LOW HIGH ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I
BLEW. BLOOM I'D- GEN VERY TRUE.
DALY TôI EGGMAN FOR. FONG FROM
NOW GIPSON. GIPSON NINE I
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN. MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA HI
MULLIN LED BY OBERNOLTE
OVERLOOKED OBERNOLTE I'VE
CHIANG CHING I. FIRST WELL TO
ONE SO THE ONE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER DOT. AND MEMBERS I DON'T
LIKE THAT UNITED- THANK THE
STAFF AND- THE GERMAN FOR A-
HAVE A GREAT ADVICE AND ALSO
THAT- GREAT ANALYSIS THAT WAS
DONE AND- IN THE LAST FEW DAYS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER DOT MEMBERS WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE FINAL ITEM FOR
THE HEARING TODAY THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE WHICH IS S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN. BY
SENATOR GALGIANI WELCOME CENTER
GOTCHA THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. THE MONEY. THIS BILL
IS TO THINK OF SHELTER STAFF A
SURROGATE PET OWNERS FOR RESCUE
ANIMALS UNDER THEIR CARE. TELL
THEM ALL CAN BE SAFE RETURNED
TO HONOR ADOPTED TO A GOOD
HOME. THE CURRENT. EXAMS THE OF
THE PAT FROM THE PATH OF.
MEDICINE AND THIS BILL SEEKS TO
MAKE SURE THAT. ACCORDING TO MY
RECENT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. WARNING NUYS.
HUNDRED THOUSAND CATS AND-
STATE Y. SINGLE YEAR. THIS BILL
WILL. IT OWNERS CAN GIVE THEIR
ANIMALS OVER THE COUNTER
MEDICATIONS BUT STATE LAW
CURRENTLY PROHIBITS NON
VETERINARY MEDICAL STAFF. FROM
BEING ABLE TO DO THE SAME. THIS
MEANS THAT IF AN ANIMAL COMES
INTO THE SHELTER WITH FLEAS
NONFAT STAFF ARE LEGALLY
EMPOWERED TO EUTHANIZE BUT NOT
TO GIVE THE MALL A FLEA PILL.
THIS BILL WILL EQUALIZE THE
ABILITY FOR ANIMAL SHELTER
CARETAKERS TO PROVIDE FOR THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF AN ANIMAL
IN THE SAME WAY THAT YOU AND I
ARE ALLOWED TO DO SO. FOR OUR
OWN PET. THIS BILL SIX. PROPER
TRAINED OFFICERS EMPLOYEES AND
VOLUNTEERS OF ANIMALS. B. AND
B. AT THE KEY TO A MESS
ADMINISTERED OVER THE COUNTER
OR NON FICTION. THE NATION'S. A
SAME WAY THAT ON DO. IN THE
LAST RECESSION PEOPLE WHO LOST
THEIR HOMES WERE BAD. WE'LL BE
REPEATING ITSELF. THE S. OF
FLOYD CAL. AND SHE- BUDGETS DO
TO THE COVERED NINETY PAN. NOW
MORE THAN EVER IT'S IMPORTANT
TO PROVIDE THE SHELTERS WITH
SOME REGULATORY RELIEF TO HELP
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF EUTHANIZED
ANIMALS AND TO SUPPORT GOVERNOR
AVENUES SAYA MAKE CALIFORNIA A
NO KILL STATE. OUT THIS BILL
EUTHANASIA WILL BE THE ONLY
MEANS TO CONTROL A COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE WITHIN SOME SHELTERS
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
DURING THE RECENT DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES WE SAW COUNTLESS
IMAGES OF VICTIMSWITH THEIR
PETS STRUGGLING TO EVACUATE TO
SAFETY. ACCORDING TO A STUDY IN
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE FOLLOWING
THE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
STORMS OF EL NINO IT WAS ON
THAT 80% OF PEOPLE WHO RE
ENTERED THE IN. ACTUATED AREA
IS RESCUE THERE PAT. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS LONG RECOGNIZED
PRINCE OF THE- TO ABANDON.
PLACE THE DESIGN VASE. THE AS
SUCH AND THOUSAND SIX
LEGISLATURE PASS A BEFORE FIFTY
WHICH REQUIRE THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO ADOPT A
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WAS EMERGENCY
SYSTEM PROGRAM AND INCORPORATE
PET EVACUATION AND RELOCATION
PROCEDURES AND TO THE STANDARD
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
THIS FURTHER INTENT BY SHELTERS
WILL BE BUILT TO PROVIDE BASIC
FIRST AID AND WE CARE. CHANGING
BACK THIS OR DRESSING WITHOUT
LIMITING THEIR CARE. TO
DISASTERS. WE HAVE ACCEPTED
AMENDMENTS AS REQUIRED BY
CONSTABULARY STAFF IN JULY PAGE
TWO AND THREE OF THE TEXT
SECTION FORTY EIGHT TWENTY
SEVEN PART EIGHT IT IS THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE BILL'S SPONSORS TO COMMIT
TENUATE. LET'S SEE. OVER THE
REGISTER ENGLISH THROUGH THE
NEXT SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS OF
THE VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD.
AS WE DISCUSSED AT LENGTH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDED TO LAST
NIGHT'S ANALYSIS REGARDING A
NEW REGULATORY ROLE FOR THE B.
AND B. AND A NEW MANDATE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SHOULD BE
DISCUSSED WITH THE WHOLE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP AS PART OF
THE VMB SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS
WHICH IS HAS BEEN ADDED AGAIN
TO SECTION FORTY EIGHT TWENTY
SEVEN POINT A- OF THE BATTLE.
HE IS PROVIDING ANIMAL CAN'T
CARE AND CONTROL MANDATE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE CONCEPT OF MANDATORY
VAT REGISTRATION BE DISCUSSED.
IN A DELIBERATIVE PROCESS WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. AND
THE REGIONAL COUNCIL OF RURAL
COUNTIES. I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT EVEN WITH THIS BILL.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND SHELTERS
WILL STILL HAVE TO. BE SUBJECT
TO STATE REQUIREMENTS THEY ARE
STILL REGULATED BY THE STATE
CDFA STATURE REQUIRES TRACKING
OF ALL MEDICATION CDPH REQUIRES
RABIES REPORTING AND FINALLY A
SHELTER WHO DOES NOT SEEK
VETERINARY CARE WHEN IT'S
NEEDED IS IN VIOLATION OF PENAL
CODE FIVE NINE SEVEN POINT ONE.
COULD BE PROSECUTED FOR ANIMAL
CONTROL ANIMAL CRUELTY OR
NEGLECT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY
IS JILL TUCKER C. E. O. OF THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION. AND MELANIE SAY
SECULAR JOHN- OF THE VALLEY
HUMANE SOCIETY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER GALGIANI I
WILL GO TO THE TWO MAIN
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE PROVIDE
UP TO THREE MINUTES FOR TOTAL
TESTIMONY WILL BEGIN THEN WITH
JILL TUCKER WITH A CALIFORNIA
ANIMAL WELFARE ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- MY NAME IS
JILL TUCKER AND I'M THE CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
SHELTER THROUGHOUT OUR STATE WE
STRONGLY REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SB THIRTY. FORTY THOUSAND.
A PROBLEM. I PERCENT. OKAY THE
LADIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE UNABLE TO OBTAIN
A VETERINARY PROMISED PERMIT
DUE TO LACK OF FUNDING WILLING
VETERINARIANS AND OUTDATED
FACILITIES THAT NEED MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS WORTH OF
IMPROVEMENTS TO MEET PERMIT
STANDARDS WITHOUT A PERMIT THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
BOARD HAS RECENTLY DECIDED THAT
THE SHELTERS ARE BREAKING THE
LAW SHOULD BE ALLOWED TRAINED
STAFF TO ADMINISTER THE FACT.
WE TREATMENT AVAILABLE TO THE
AVERAGE THAT AFFECT OVER THE
COUNTER AT ANY FEED STORE
PLEASE SHOPPERS WITH THE
ABILITY YOU CANNOT CANNOT BUT
NOT VACCINATE THEM TO PREVENT
THE SPREAD OF DISEASE. AND SOME
UNDER REPORT OF OUR STATE
CHILDREN COUNT ON THEIR ABILITY
TO ADMINISTER OVER THE COUNTER
PRODUCTS WHILE UTILIZING THE
SERVICES OF PRIVATE PART THAT
NERI HOSPITAL TO TREAT AT PAT
IN THE REGION THIS MODEL FOR A
VETERINARY CARE THE. I THINK.
THERE TO PROVIDE THE BASIC
FACTS AND- WILL BE SO IN THE
END OF THE- AND SCOTT. YOU SOME
pFOR TO CLOSE. WE ARE THE
SADDENED BY THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS PRESENTED LAST NIGHT
THAT WILL REQUIRE SHELTERS TO
FIND HIRE AND PAY OF THAT
MERION. TO MAINTAIN A
REASONABLE PHYSICAL PRESS THEIR
FACILITY THIS IS SIMPLY NOT
POSSIBLE IN SOME AREAS. WE NEED
YOUR ACT TODAY REGULATORY OR
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS THAT IMPOSE
SIGNIFICANT UNFUNDED MANDATES
ON ANIMAL SHELTERS. ARE
OBJECTIONABLE IN UNDER GOOD
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS AND
DOWNRIGHT CATASTROPHIC AT THIS
TIME. PANDEMIC BUDGET. BROAD
AND DEEP SHELTERS. AND RESOURCE
WHILE BRACING FOR AN INFLUX OF
PETS AND PEOPLE LOSE THEIR JOBS
AND ULTIMATELY THEIR HOMES.
PLEASE ENSURE THAT THE SHELTER
CAN CONTINUE TO HELP HOMELESS
PETS AND PROVIDE THE BASIC CARE
THEY NEED BY SUPPORTING SB
THIRTY FORTY SEVEN AS WRITTEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NECK HE WITNESSED. HI MY
NAME'S MELANIE SADEK I MEAN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
NONPROFIT ANIMAL SHELTER AND
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA I AM
PLEASED TO AMAZING
VETERINARIANS AND THE BENEFITS
OF HOLDING A VETERINARY
PREMISES PERMIT I AM ALSO THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NUMBER WELFARE EDUCATION. I'M
HOPING MY TESTIMONY TODAY CAN
HELP EXPLAIN WHY SIXTY ONE
ANIMAL WELFARE GROUPS IN
CALIFORNIA- IN THE COURT OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN ALBRITTON
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE
CURRENT PRACTICES IN ANIMAL
SHELTERS. ANIMAL SHELTERS
CODIFIED BEST PRACTICES THAT
WERE PUT IN PLACE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT I. FORGOT
ABOUT YOU. INCLUDE IN THE UC
DAVIS MATTER TEAM AND THAT NOT
A BOARD. GUIDELINES ALSO THAN
WRECK. FOR SHALL MEDICINE TO
HELP CONTROL THE THING IS AN
ELEMENT AND SHELTER. AND THE
ROUNDING COMMUNITY. WHEN YOU'VE
GOT FOR. THE GOAL IS TO PROVIDE.
TO SHELTERS BUT MEN THAT ABOUT
PRACTICE WERE PERMISSIBLE
WITHOUT HIRING A VETERAN. SB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN CODIFIED
GUIDELINES AND HAVE ONGOING
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS FOR
SHELTER STAFF. TO HELP YOU
UNDERSTAND HOW. THE ALLOWABLE
VETERINARY PROCEDURES AREN'T AT
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN IT'S BEST
TO COMPARE THEM TO A PRIVATE.
YEAH EIGHT. ANIMAL WE CAN BUY
OVER COUNTER. THAT STORE AND
BACK NEED AT HOME WE CAN BUY IN.
TOPICAL CONTROL AND WE CAN
VISIT AND THAT AND BEGIN A
TREATMENT PLAN TO FOLLOW. WHICH
MAY INCLUDE ORAL IN. IT SB
THIRTY FORTY SEVEN ALBRITTON
DOESN'T PASS SHELTERS CAN'T
PROVIDE OVER THE COUNTER
VACCINATIONS DIFFERENT PREVENT
THE SPREAD OF ILLNESS. THEY
CAN'T ADMINISTER TOPICAL FLEA
TREATMENT WHICH STOP BY THE
PARASITE THE COMPACT HUMAN. AND
THEY CAN'T TAKE A SHELTER
ANIMAL TO A VETERINARIAN AND
THEN FOLLOW THE PRESCRIBED
TREATMENT PLANT. THE ONLY.
MEDICAL PROCEDURE THEY CAN
PERFORM. THE JOB. SB. THIRTEEN
SEVEN THIRTEEN FORTY. THANK YOU.
THE RESULTS OF THE DENTIST TO.
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO FIND OR HOW. ABOUT
YOU. I URGE SUPPORT SB. FORTY
SEVEN AS- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT CONCLUDES THE PORTION OF
THE MEETING FOR KEY WITNESSES
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. BENHAM
OPERATOR WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN
UP THE PORTION OF THE MEETING
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC NOW
TO CALL IN TO SIGNIFY THEIR
SUPPORT WITH M. FEELING ONLY.
PLEASE OPEN HEART WHEN THIS
WISHING TO SIGNIFY THEIR
SUPPORT NAY MANIPULATION ONLY.
IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS STAR AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME ONCE
AGAIN THAT'S GOING TO BE STAR
AND THEN ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO WIDE ONE
OLD THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS JENNIFER HEARING HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA THE SAN DIEGO
HUMANE SOCIETY AND BEST FRIENDS
ANIMAL SOCIETY WE SUPPORT THEM
IN PRINT AND OPPOSED THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED IN THE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT REPORTER WIND ONE OH
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CORY SELLS A LITTLE ON THE HALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AS- THANK YOU. HERE
NEXT DOOR TO WHINE ONE OH TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TRACY RAIMES WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTS OF CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF OUR THIRTY SEVEN
MEMBER COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AT IN PRINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT DOOR TO WIDE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI LEVY DAN CABBAGES SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE ATTORNEY FOR BEST
FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN AS PRINTED BUT
OPPOSE ANY FURTHER AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOUR NECK
FORTY ONE ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS IVY
REESE CALLING ON BEHALF OF A
SILLY ANIMAL SERVICES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE THREE FOUR
SEVEN. THANK YOU RYAN ONE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN NUMBER
NICOLE KIDMAN ON BEHALF OF SAN
BERNARDINO. IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY AT THE END. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE FORTY FOR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT ONE FORTY FOUR.
HI THIS IS JULIE JOHNSON WITH
THE BAKERSFIELD SPCA I'M IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
SEVEN AS WRITTEN. BANK YOUR
NEXT DOOR TO LINE. ONE FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON DONNA SITES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. SECURE NEXT FORTY ONE
ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON IS IN BRICKS
REPRESENTING THE ASPCA AND
SUPPORT- SB THIRTEEN FORTY
SEVEN AS WRITTEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS SEVEN
INTERFERE WITH THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF TRUCKEE TAHOE AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE THREE
FOUR SEVEN AS WRITTEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND HAVE YOUR MIND OR
IF YOU WISH WITHOUT SHOW OF
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS STAR AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. DO OF
ONE MARIN CURE WOULD BE ONE
MOMENT.
RIGHT ONE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS LAURIE MORTON WHILE I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SAN MATTEO
ANIMAL CONTROL AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY FORTY
SEVEN AS WRITTEN. OKAY THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER RIGHT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. BECAUSE.
METAM OPERATOR WOULD YOU JUST
KILEY DO A ONE MORE CHECK JUST
IN CASE THERE ARE ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU REVEREND
BINDER IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS STAR AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
A COUPLE MORE IN Q. IT'LL JUST
BE ONE MOMENT. BLIND ONE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND I
WANTED TO SPOT LIGHT ONE FIVE
SIX. GARY COOPER WITH THE POP
PROJECT IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AS WRITTEN. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANGELA YEAH EIGHT WITH THE
ANIMAL SHELTER ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM IN SANTA BARBARA
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN AS WRITTEN.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE. EQUAL OPPORTUNITY A
FULL PARTICIPATION WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE PORTION OF THE
MEETING FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TWO THIRDS
OF THE PUBLIC. AS KEY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION MOREOVER VIBE
THAT YOU WILL NOT TIME THAT
WE'VE PROVIDED ENOUGH FODDER TO
THE PERSON I SEE IN THE GALLERY
WHICH IS THE- CARL. HALF OF THE
CAP VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION PLEASE BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
AM CRISTINA TO COPPER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE INTENSE
NEGOTIATIONS WE WERE UNABLE TO
REACH A COMPROMISE AND THE CDMA
REMAINS OPPOSED. UNLESS THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS ARE WILLING
TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. THREE
QUARTERS OF THE ANIMAL SHELTER
IN THE STATE. UNDER THE
WATCHFUL EYE OF THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL. BECAUSE VETERINARY
MEDICINE IS BEING PRACTICED
INCLUDING SPAY NEUTER SURGE. IS
EMMA LIKE. THIS BILL WOULD
TREAT EIGHTY OR MORE ANIMAL
SHELTERS DIFFERENTLY WITH THE
SPONSORS WE WENT THAT THEY
AREN'T REALLY PER. A VETERINARY
MEDICINE BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST
MINISTERING VACCINES NOW
PRINTER. MEDICINE FOR STATE.
CONCERN IS. WHAT A LOT
LAYPERSONS INCLUDE STAFF AND
VOLUNTEERS AT SHELTERS TO
DIAGNOSE AND TREAT AND MAKE
MEDICAL DECISIONS FOR SHELTER
ANIMALS WITHOUT HAVING A
RELATIONSHIP WITH A
VETERINARIAN AND WITH VERY
LITTLE TRAINING ONLY SIX HOURS
SPOT. HAS SAID IS FOR THE SAME
NON FIRST. THAT YOU ARE NOT TO
GET. IF YOU STORE GIVE TRUMP.
HOME AND THAT'S PLAUSIBLE BUT
MOST PEOPLE DON'T ATTEMPT TO
DIAGNOSE THEIR OWN ANIMALS THEY
GO TO THEIR VETERINARIAN THE
VETERINARIAN TELLS THEM WHAT
MEDICINE WOULD BE PASSED HOW
OFTEN TO TAKE IT AND WHAT SIDE
EFFECTS LOOK OUT FOR THEN THE
OLDER ADMINISTER THESE NON
FICTION MEDICINES THAT ARE. IN
THIS BILL OR TALK ABOUT. SINCE
MEDIC. FUNDS FOR THOUSANDS OF
ANIMALS ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS BY
THE SPONSORS WAS THE DIFFICULTY
OF FINDING A VETERINARIAN ON A
LIMITED BASIS CDMA OFFERED
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE REJECTED
WHERE BY A VETERINARIAN WOULD
HAVE ONLY A LIMITED PRESENT AT
A SHELTER. ONLY PHONE CETERA
NOT TIME. NOT PART TIME. WE
FELT THE AMENDMENTS WERE VERY
REASONABLE THEY CREATED GREAT
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE SHELTER AND
THE VETERINARIAN I WANT TO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
LEAVE YOUR STAFF FOR THE
COUNTLESS HOURS OF WORK THAT
WENT IN THANK YOU FOR A PATH
FORWARD. WE SUPPORT THE AMEND
CONTAINED IN THE COMMITTEE AND
NOW THIS M. THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THAT END
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THIRTY
VERY MUCH I MOVE ON TO THE
SECOND WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
THE SECOND KEY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AND I SEE THAT WE
HAVE A BOARD MEMBER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
BOARD. HELLO MY NAME IS
JENNIFER LAREDO AND I AM THE
REGISTERED VETERINARY
TECHNICIAN MEMBER OF THE
VETERINARY BOARD. THE BOARD
TOOK AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL DUE TO THE
REMOVAL OF ANY OVERSIGHT AND
THE INEVITABLE HARM THAT WOULD
IMPACT THE STATE STORABLE. THIS
ISSUE IS ESPECIALLY. TO ME AS I
SPENT THIRTEEN YEARS WORKING IN
AN OPEN ADMISSION MUNICIPAL
CITY AND COUNTY ANIMAL SHELTER
THE IMPOUNDED. OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND ANIMALS PER YEAR.
DURING THAT TIME I PERSONALLY
WITNESSED THE RESPONSIBILITY
THAT COMES WITH CARING FOR
SHELTER ANIMALS AND THE
CONSEQUENCES. ARE AFTER THAT
OVERSIGHT. I THINK ANIMALIZE
PLACED IN JEOPARDY AS A RESULT
OF IMPROPER TREATMENT
ADMINISTERED BY UNTRAINED OR
INEXPERIENCED STAFF. I HAVE
BEEN PRESSURED TO PERFORM AN
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT IN THE
ABSENCE OF A VETERINARIAN. I
HAVE WIPED AWAY MY OWN BLOOD
SWEAT AND TEARS TO COUNCIL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
COME TO US FOR HELP WHEN THEY
HAD NOWHERE ELSE TO TURN. MOST
IMPORTANTLY I HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEND MY VOICE TO
BE ANIMAL COULD NOT SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES. AS. WELL AND THAT.
HE SPENT OVER FIVE WORK WITH
STATE. TO FIND WAY TO HELP. OUT
PROVIDE CARE ANIMALS. HELP WITH
HOURS SPENT MORE COLLAB. TO
COME UP WITH. CLEARLY WRITTEN
BY. ALL TO LIVE WITH. EVERY
INVOLVED HAD BEST IN OF
SHELTERING AT HEART WELL WE
TRIED TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO
ISSUES THAT HAVE PLAGUED THE
SHELTER INDUSTRY FOR DECADES.
EVERY READ THE ANIMALS NEED
SUPPORT. SB THIRTEEN FORTY
SEVEN HOWEVER WELL INTENDED
WILL CAUSE SIGNIFICANT
UNINTENDED HARM TO THOSE
ANIMALS AND TO THE STAFF.
OVERSIGHT IS NOT THE ANSWER THE
BOARD W. PUSHING THE HARD WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE STEPHANIE
ANALYSIS WITH THE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS AND WE BELIEVE.
NECESSARY AND WHAT LEVY ARE
CONCERNED. HOWEVER WE CONTINUE
TO OPPOSE. UNLESS AMENDED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONE
NOW ON MADAM OPERATOR TO
PORTION THE MEETING FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. WITH THEIR NAME
AND AFFILIATIONS ONLY IF THEY
WISH TO DO SO. THAT OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ARE
AT. ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANKS
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS THE STAR AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE IN HERE JUST BE ONE
MOMENT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WORLDWIDE ONE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE ONE
SIX ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I
INCREASE THE METROPOLE WITH
STRAY CAT ALLIANCE ONE OF THE
LARGEST CAT- PROTECTION AND
ADVOCACY IN RESCUE
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE COUNTRY WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN AS WE WANT
TO WRITTEN AND WE DO NOT AGREE
WITH THE RECENT AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU NEXT DOOR TO WIDE ONE
HUNDRED NINETEEN NINE ONE ONE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS BRYAN SIKORA AND I AM A
SMALL ANIMAL VETERINARY OF
COLOR WHOSE BODY PRACTICING IN
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS I'VE WORKED IN BOTH
PRIVATE PRACTICE AND WORKED IN
VOLUNTEER. AT BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SHELTERS AND RESCUE
GROUPS ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE S.
B. THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN. I'M
GLAD FRIEDMAN THAT ALL WORKED
OUT LAST NIGHT THANK YOU FOR
MUCH ALL MINIMUM YOU CAN COME
AND WANT TO THE NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU AT THE REMINDER IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS THE STAR AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YOU HAVE ONE
MARIN CURATOR SB ONE MOMENT.
OVER A WIDE ONE SIX BEFORE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME
IS RENEE MORALIS I AM I
RECENTLY LIKE NUCLEAR PLANTS
AFFILIATED WITH A CALIFORNIA
LICENSE REQUIRED COMPOUND AND-
I. NORM I AM STRONGLY TO IT.
ONE TWO THREE SEVEN. FOR A LOT.
AND AS A REMINDER IF YOU WISH
TO BEGIN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS STAR AND THEN ZERO AT
THAT TIME. I HAVE NO FURTHER
MIND THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MADAM OPERATOR AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION OULD YOU
KINDLY ASK AGAIN FOR THE FINAL
TIME FOR ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS STAR
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
I HAVE NO LIFE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM OPERATOR A NUMBER IN A
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION SENATOR GALGIANI-
THAT- YOU ARE PRESENTING THE
BILL AS IS WITHOUT ACCEPTING
THE COMEDIAN MEDS. THAT WE
PRESENTED TO THE OFFICES JUST
FOR CLARIFICATION IS THAT
CORRECT. I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THAT YOU ALLOW ME TO ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE WITHOUT THE AMENDMENTS
THOSE AMENDMENTS WERE DISCUSSED
IN OUR JULY. AND MEETINGS AND
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAD WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND MEMBERS OF
YOUR STAFF AND IT WAS DECIDED
IN JULY THAT TIME. THAT NEEDED
TO BROADEN THE STAKEHOLDER
GROUP DISCUSSIONS AND THAT
THERE WOULD BE A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY DO THAT NEXT YEAR
IN THE SENSE. REVIEW PROCESS
I'M AS PART OF BRING THAT WE
DID TAKE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE ON XIN FORTY EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN PAGES TWO AND THREE WHICH
TO SIT IN A WHICH IS. THE IN.
THE LEAD. TO REVEALING SHELTER
OPERATIONS AND THE ADEQUATE-
OVERSIGHT OF THAT ACT PLEASE
PERFORMED BY LICENSED
VETERINARY PROFESSIONALS.
ALTERNATE PLEASE AND TELL TO
HEAR THANK. I MADE IT. TO THE-
THROUGH THE NEXT TEN RATE
PROCESS OF THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOY. PERCENT DECEPTIVE
AGENCY SECTION FORTY HUNDRED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ENERGY WE
WILL TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WAS WELL AWARE OF
WHAT THE BILL WAS BEING
PRESENTED IN FRONT OF THEM AND
YOUR REQUEST IS TO BE HAVE THE
BILL. BEING CONSIDERED AS IT IS
WITHOUT THE SUGGESTED
COMMITMENTS CORRECT THAT IS MY
REQUEST FOR WONDERFUL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER. WHEN I BRING
THE DISCUSSION- TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. WILL BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. HEY
MISTER CHAIRED. IS A- FAIRLY
UNIQUE SITUATIONS AND IN MY
EXPERIENCE HERE WERE- WE'RE
NEGOTIATION DISCUSSION AND THAT
AND EMENTA I GUESS THAT DATES
BACK TO. LATE JULY BUT I THINK
IT WAS SENT TO PRINT ON AUGUST
FOURTH IF I HAVE MY- FACTS
CORRECT AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY
THERE WERE ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE.
RECOMMENDED JOB A BY STAFF IN
THE CHAIR- AS OF- AS OF
YESTERDAY IT'S JUST THAT IT'S A
LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT ESPECIALLY
AT THIS LATE MOMENT TO BE
EVALUATING. AMENDMENTS BUT IT
IT DOES SEEM TO ME THAT- THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL. AS FAR BACK.
AS AS JULY WAS OFFERING TO-
EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE- THAT WERE BEFORE HER AT
THAT TIME BUT ALSO CONTINUE ON
INTO DISCUSSION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND TO- NEXT YEAR
AND THIS BILL PRESENTS- ISSUES
OF GREAT IMPORTANCE TO- ANIMALS
THAT ARE IN SHELTERS AND THE
CARE FOR AND IN CALIFORNIA.
FIVE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE DO SOMETHING GOD I HAVE NO
DOUBT THAT TO A READING OF
STATE OTHERS ARE OKAY
ADDITIONAL AND RESULT AND- OKAY
YEAH I THINK THE THING TO DO.
THIS FOR A NEW SITUATION IS
MOVE THE BILL WITH THE UNDER
THAT THE AUTHOR IS AGREEING TO
A CONVENE ALL STATE OTHERS
CONTINUE THE- PROCESS OF
DISCUSSION OF THESE ISSUES AND
TO NEXT YEAR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND I'M HAPPY TO SOME
ADDITIONAL CON COMMENT I SHOULD
THERE NOT BE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
AT THIS TIME YOU SEEN. ARE
TELLING HER THAT AS A MOTION
ASSEMBLY IF THAT'S ALRIGHT YEAH
SURE- THE MOTION IT IS TO. MOVE
THE BILL AS WRITTEN WITHOUT THE
COMMITTEE AND THEN CAN I PLEASE
MAKE A CLARIFICATION SURE SIR I
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT IN
NO WAY SHAPE OR THAT MY INTENT.
ELDERS OFF WOULD BE A TO DIE.
AND TREAT I AM MYSELF WOULD
ABSOLUTELY NOT GO ALONG WITH
THAT I'M AN ANIMAL LOVER AND
THE FORMER SPCA VOLUNTEER WHO
FOSTERED UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED
CATS AND KITTENS I'VE HAD
SITUATIONS WHERE I. A CAT THAT
HAD AN ABORTION- IN MY HOME AND
EXPECTED AND I TOOK RIGHT TO
THE VET WE HAD THE U. RANGE
WITH. IT FIVE. CALVET FROM ONE
TURNED MAINLY LATER AFTER
FOSTERING THAT CASH THAT THE
CAT HAD FELINE AIDS- I AM VERY
WELL AWARE OF THE DANGERS THAT
COULD BE AND WE WERE VERY
EXPLICIT IN THIS BILL. THAT
PERSON. THAT IS NOT. IN ANY
BEING THAT IS MEDICATION THAT'S
PRESCRIBED VETERINARY BY
VETERINARIAN WOULD STILL HAVE
TO BE PRESCRIBED UNDER A
VETERINARIAN AND OVERSEEN BY.
VETERINARIAN IT IS NOT MY
INTENT IN ANY WAY TO GET THERE
CLOSE TO ALLOW. STAFF TO
DIAGNOSE. AND THE CONDITION IN
THE EVENT THAT AN ADAM DOWN BY
AN ANIMAL CONTROL OFFICER IN A
FIELD AND IS WOUNDED UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE ANIMAL CONTROL
OFFICER IS ALLOWED TO QUOTE
UNQUOTE DESTROY THAT MALL. I
BELIEVE THAT IT IS BETTER WELL
FOR. THE MERCHANTS DAY TO BE P.
FIVE PROVIDE ANIMAL AND THAT IS
PART OF THE EXTENT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
GALGIANI. ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
FROM CAN MEMBERS I CAN ALSO
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT AS WELL-
TO THIS- BUT BEFORE I DO SO I
JUST SAW A HAND FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS THE CHANCE AGAIN-
MEMBERS THIS BILL AS AS
PRESENTED. IS WITH INTENT TO
EXPAND ACCESS AS THE AUTHOR HAS
SUGGESTED WITH THE EXEMPTION OF
THE MINISTER OF VETERINARY
MEDICINE. TO ALLOW FOR
INDIVIDUALS VOLUNTEERS WITH SIX
HOURS OF TRAINING OR SO TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE SIMILAR TYPE OF.
ALL I'M MORE. FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE GONE BNP VETERINARIANS
WHICH HAVE INCLUDED LICENSING
EXAMS LICENSING FEES GOING TO
SCHOOL SIMILARLY THE BORDER OF.
THE TWENTY BOARD OF VETERINARY
BOARD HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
REVOKE A LICENSE AND OR
REPRIMAND INDIVIDUAL SHOULD BE
SIGNIFICANT HARM. SO THE BILL
PROCESS DOES NOT ALLOW FOR THE
MECHANISM FOR THE STATE AND THE
BOARD AS ARTICULATED TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT THE BASIC
PROTECTIONS WITHIN THE
FRAMEWORK OF. PASSIONS THAT
REGULATORY. AND SO TO HAVE
VOLUNTEERS WHO DON'T HAVE THE
SAME TYPE OF TRAINING PROVIDE
FIRST AID AND VACCINATIONS IS A
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE BUT WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANT INTENT
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO WHICH WHY
WE DID NOT SUGGEST IN THE
AMENDMENTS TO RECALL ARMORING
THAT IS WHY. WITHOUT OF THAT.
SIR FOR K. YEAH HOUSE RECORD
YOU READ. TO ALLOW FOR THE FOR
THE STATE TO LOOK AT THE
OVERSIGHT PROTECTIONS IN PLACE
SO THAT SHOULD THERE BE
SIGNIFICANT HARM THAT THE STATE
HAS FRATERNITY TO SUPPORT THOSE
CONSUMERS SIMILARLY MEMBERS
ALONG THE REALM OF BUSINESSES
PASSIONS WE DO A NUMBER LICENSE
CATEGORIES WHAT I. WHETHER IT'S
IN THE I THINK GOING THERE IS
ARM WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK AT THE BASIC. IN PLACE. IF
THERE'S COMPLAIN. THE BILL
PRESENTED THERE IS THERE ARE
NONE IN THIS FOR THE SAFEGUARDS
THE FOR OF BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS. AND AS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS KNOW WE TAKE A FAIR
AMOUNT OF TIME WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF AND WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AND THE BOARD TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS A BALANCE IN ACCESS
BUT SIMPLY WE WOULD NOT WANT TO
SEE. THOSE THAT ARE NOT LIFE
PROVIDE VACCINATIONS. ON COVERT
OR OTHER. RELATED ITEMS SO
AGAIN WE BELIEVE THAT THE
REGISTRATION TO HELP SUPPORT
AND COMPROMISED IS THAT OF A
REGISTRATION. NOT CERTIFICATION
NOT. A CENSURE BUT REGISTRATION
AND THE REGISTRATION AGAIN
PROVIDES THAT FROM OR TO ALLOW
FOR WHAT WE THINK WE
COLLECTIVELY WANT TO SEE WHICH
INCREASED TAX. AND THAT'S WHAT.
THE REGISTRATION. TO STILL
RESERVE THAT PROTECTION AND
UNFORTUNATELY WITHOUT THE
PROTECTIONS WE HAVE HEARD
SPECIFICALLY FROM THE
VETERINARIAN BORE. THAT THEY DO
NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK AT. THE POTENTIAL CRIMINAL
INTENT. OR PERHAPS. DRUG
OFFENSES THAT MIGHT BE.
SUBJECTED TO IT WITHIN THE
SHELTERS GET SOME BASIC
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE TO
SOMETHING THAT WE TRY TO LOOK
AT. AS WELL. FOR THE SENATE AND
THAT'S WHY. WITH THE
FUNDAMENTAL AGAIN WE COULD'VE
GONE STRONGER ON STRICT
LICENSURE OR EVEN ON
CERTIFICATION BOETTCHER SAID
SIMPLY REGISTRATION. SO AGAIN
THAT'S WHY WE ARE SO SUGGESTING
THAT THE AUTHOR EXCEPT THE
AMEND SIZES BUT WE WILL BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO. THE AND I WAS
MAKING A SECOND WITH. AN
IMPRINT THIS IS. THANKS I NEED
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM CAN
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME. I SEE
NINE HUNDRED JANET DO WISH TO
CLOSE. I HAVE A PROCEDURAL
QUESTION. IF THE MOMENT THE
FIRST MOTION DOES NOT PASS FOR
THE BILL AS IT IS. WILL THERE
BE AN ON THE FOR A SECOND
MOTION FOR THE BILL AS AMENDED
SURE THIS COMMITTEE WOULD BE
DELIGHTED TO SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO WHICH
WE'VE HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
YOU BECAUSE WE VERY MUCH
RECOGNIZED. THE TICKET
EXPERTISE. IN THAT YOU HAVE IN
THIS AREA AND WE WANT TO SEE
THIS BE SUCCESSFUL BUT WE HONOR
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE PROTECTIONS IN PLACE.
HAVING SAID THAT THE ANSWER
QUESTION IS. SURE HE WOULD BE
TO MAKE THE MOST FOR THE BILL
WITH THE CANADIAN MEN'S SHOULD
THE PREVIOUS MOTION FAILED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER GALGIANI
HAVING SAID THAT- THERE HAS
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND- AS
I MENTIONED- THIS IS FOR THE OF
A MOTION WITH THE BILL AND
PRINT THE COMMITTEE MEN'S. AT
THIS DOESN'T DOES NOT ENJOY A
CONDITION COMMITTEE SECRETARY
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
UP. S. THIRTEEN SEVEN MOTION TO
PASS TO. LOW NO NO NO ARAMBULA.
BLAM REVIVED CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
DALY DALY AYE EGGMAN. THEY WERE
NOT VOTING FOR ARE FONG. FONG
NOT VERY. MARGAI GIPSON. GIVEN
OPERATOR GLORIA OR IN A VERY
GRAYSON GRAYSON OFFERING HOLDEN
HOLDEN NOT READING IRWIN.
MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA NOT
MONNING MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE ACTING.
FOUR SIX ONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WOOD TO THE CAN IS CENTER
WHICH ALLOW COME ON THE
COMMITTEE THIS WITH THE BILL OF
THE BILL THAT YOU'RE PRESENTED
WITH A COMMITTEE. YEAH THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER.
YES MOTION BY SUMMER BLOOM
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON THAT THIS JUST ENJOYED
TO PASS RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
THIRTY SEVEN DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HI NO I ARAMBULA. HELLO WHEN I
CHEN. CHEN NOT VERY TRUE. DR
DOLLY. DOES NOT VERY EGGMAN
ADMIN I FLORA. FOR NOT VERY
FONG. FOR NOT WEARING GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GLORIA FOR AYE
GRAYSON GREAT HOLDEN. WHAT ARE
IRWIN HI MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA
AYE MULLIN MODI OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING TAKING.
THERE IS A LIMIT OF.
ZERO
COLLEGE'S COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE
NEED TO TAKE A MOTION ON
RECONSIDERATION- WITH. BOB
CONSIDERATION. MOTION AT MOTION
BY SOME THEM. AND THEN THE
SECOND BY MISTER GLORIA. AND
THAT. WITH UNANIMOUS CONSENT
ANYONE OBJECT WITH UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE CONSIDERATION
FIRST. OKAY NOW THEN DOES DOES
IT WILL GO BACK TO THAT.
APPROPRIATE MOTION AT HAND
WHICH IS TO MOVE THE BILL WITH
THE CANADIAN MEN'S AND THAT WAS
OUR BEEN IN MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS TAKEN BY A
FAMILY MEMBER GIPSON. WOULD YOU
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGAIN SO THAT WE CAN GET THIS.
DONE CORRECTLY YES SB THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS FLOW
I KNOW I. ARAMBULA BLAM. HI
CHINA GEN NUMBER NINETY CHAU.
TO OUR DAILY. DYNAMITING EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE FOR FOREIGN OFFERING
FOR FROM GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GLORIA GLORIA AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN. AYE IRWIN
WHEN I MCCARTY. THE AYE MEDINA
MEDINA HIGH MULLIN MULLIN AYE
OBERNOLTE RELIGION OFFERING
TRAINING. FIRST QUARTER THERE
ARE. DOES YOUR WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN
THANK YOU THANK YOU HOWEVER NOW
GO BACK INTO ORDER THEM FOR.
THE FINAL. ADDITIONAL ADD ON.
AND WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR A FIVE MINUTES FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ALSO BE
PRESENT. SO WE'RE GOING OUT
FILE ORDER. AND EFFECTIVE. I
VOTED ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MOTION TO STUDY PAST OF
OPERATIONS FOR SB FIVE SEVEN
THREE SB SIX FORTY THREE SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR AND WITH THE
MOTION OF JUST TO PASS TO ON SB
TWELVE FORTY FOUR IRWIN. BERMAN
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN WHAT I.
CHANGE. EIGHTEEN TO THERE ARE.
pDO PASS OUT AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATE. HI. AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY MOTIONS DO PASS AS
A MANAGER OF OPERATIONS. CHIU
NOT VERY. GRAYSON. SB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY. GRAYSON OFFERING.
MCCARTY. AB THIRTY THREE THIRTY
MOTIONS YOU PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS MCCARTY. MCCARTY
I. GLORIA HI.
YOUR CALL. AB
THIRTY THREE THIRTY VOTERS TEND
TO SIX. THANK YOU. WELCOME BACK
SB THIRTY SEVEN IS THE BEST
APPROPRIATIONS TRUE. HI MCCARTY
MCCARTY I CHIANG. THREE I.
NINETY TWO ZERO. THREE EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHT MOTIONS YOU PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU. YOU ARE.
BUT IS NINETY TWO ZERO. SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN MOTIONS
DEPRESSED APPROPRIATIONS CHILL.
CHIU AYE EGGMAN. SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN MOTIONS DISASTER
PREPARATIONS. AND WHEN I. FOR
IRWIN. AND I MCCARTY RT I. FOR
THE SEVENTY TO ONE.
ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. TING TING I.
WHAT IS NIGHT NINETEEN ZERO.
SB
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVENTY PASTOR
PREPARATIONS CHIANG. ON THE
SECOND MOTION SB THIRTEEN FORTY
SEVEN TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS TANG TO ACT. I
HAVE A WHOLE. ON THE FIRST
MOTION SB THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
TRUE TO OUR- ON THE SECOND
MOTION SB THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN
DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS JAIL JULY. SO IF
YOU CALL US.
YEAH.
WHAT ABOUT
ON SB THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN FIVE
ON THE SECOND MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
THURBER'S THE THIRTEEN TO ZERO.
THREE THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN ON
SECOND MOTION TO PASS AS A
MANAGER PREPARATIONS ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE. BUT AS FOURTEEN
ZERO.
ON THE CONTENT HONORED
VOTERS IN NINETEEN ZERO THOSE
BILLS ARE OUT. AB THIRTY THREE
THIRTY VOTERS TEND TO SIX OF
THOSE OUT. SB SIXTY SEVEN
BORDERS NINETY TWO ZERO THE
BILLS OUT. SB EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT VOTERS NINETY TWO ZERO
THE BILLS OUT.
THREE TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. THERE WERE
SIXTEEN TO ONE OF THOSE OUT. ON
THE SECOND MOTION SB THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN. THE VOTERS
FOURTEEN TO ZERO THE BILLS OUT.
OKAY THANK YOU CAN.